[Music]
been a long time coming it happened
we've been sitting here with these masks
i'm over the mask two years two years
when we started this g3 stuff this
gorilla collective gc stuff i i mean
we had to rock these yeah but i think
it's about time it's about time to take
them off let's take these off and let's
get right into it people what is
happening everyone welcome to gc3 the
gorilla collective 3 summer showcase the
least pretentious showcase you will see
this summer that hat trick the 3p the
menage anyway
i am your host justin woodward
co-founder of the mix the media indie
exchange and terribly entertainment and
advisor of the black game developer fund
as well as black voice to gaming i'm
with my amazing co-host the green eyed
bandit can't stand it candace mckinney
how's it going candy it's going great
justin i am so happy to be here
co-hosting gc3 and kicking off the
summer with everybody
really kick it off tough the gorilla
collective was created because
everything was fragmented in terms of
the press and event organization during
the zombie apocalypse of 2020 so we
decided to come together organize and
deploy showcases with our fellow
independent hustlers in the game
industry and add some flavor and style
to the industry to give folks a creative
jolt during the chaos that was ensuing
the gorilla collector's main message is
unity we are carrying on the tradition
of organization with these showcases
with leading game studios publishers and
industry leaders independently to share
announcements gameplay reveals updates
and drops from studios of all sizes
direct to everyone watching worldwide
so this week we started black voices and
gaming and today we will blow things up
with gc3 showcasing a wide range of
games and then we'll hand it off to our
friends over at wholesome games for
their wholesome direct showcase later on
this week we'll have the gc 3.5 where
we're going to share some fresh games
that are crispy and lit they're gonna be
mad crispy but not burnt before we get
started we have to give a huge shout out
to our sponsors playstation razer astro
gaming tencent our fellow devs and
publishers 11-bit acappara all-in games
assemble entertainment aurora punks
freedom graffiti gravity games arise
hero craft modern wolf raw fury tiny
build wire productions also salute to
the developers who played a role in the
showcase they have contributed their
games and resources to make this
possible
and once again you guys we've teamed up
with the fine folks at valve to showcase
our stream on their platform in order to
support the devs be sure to check out
the gorilla collective 3 event page on
steam where you can learn more about the
games buy games that are available now
or add them to your wish list for the
games that haven't been released yet
these wish lists really help the devs so
let's do it definitely check out the
wish lists support the devs they will
love it shout out to our broadcasting
partners for supporting the showcase and
the developers on the stream twitch
steam
ign of course gamespot we are trying
something out new this time around uh
we're going to be doing key drops
through qr codes randomly during the
showcase so please have your phones
ready to grab some codes from the
gorilla collective gc3 also let's say
hello to our mix master gorilla squad
partners who are co-streaming today you
all are amazing be sure to check out all
of the great reactions and commentary
from them
let's get started with the first set of
games that go od
this summer beginning with a hardcore
soul seeker simulation a soul-like
action rpg as well as some up-and-coming
games and a few exclusive surprises on
the horizon for release
let's get started i can't wait
all squads report in kilos ready for
takeoff
[Music]
[Applause]
hey
what's up
oh yeah
whoo
[Music]
oh yeah
uh
[Music]
laughs
hahaha
[Music]
[Applause]
candy alaloth has come such a long way
and is looking really impressive i
remember when that game just got started
looking forward to checking that out as
well as boundaries shooting folks in
space what coming up next we're gonna
get serious with some games that may
scare you a little and then transition
to some more narrative driven situations
that might make you contemplate life we
got a full rollercoaster of emotions
coming up let's go let's go
[Music]
so
ah
[Music]
so
hmm
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
uh
[Music]
all right
[Applause]
[Music]
it
is under the influence of any drugs
or if it was actually a witchcraft
ritual as indicated by the evidence
found at the scene
suggesting the latter police officers
found books at the scene containing
strange symbols candles
the first victim was her own 75 year old
father
madison mutilated his body in such a way
that his face was not recognizable
[Music]
hours later madison continues
this is impossible
this place didn't look like this a
second ago
chains
maybe i can break them with something
[Music]
what the hell am i doing
the doorbell
i gotta get to the front door
[Music]
foreign
rated teen
walter
[Music]
oh my god
oh my god is this right
[Music]
foreign
hey guys it's carl from 11b studios i'm
glad to be back at guerrilla collective
because we've been pretty busy for the
last two years so first of all i would
like to introduce luquitaker from state
of play the creators of southwest circle
because they would like to tell you more
about how they are creating games
i'm luke whitaker i'm creative director
of state of play we made south of the
circle which is a narrative adventure
game set in antarctica in the 1960s
[Music]
we've decided on such an unusual setting
because i was fascinated by the surreal
beauty of antarctica
our lead character peter's experience in
antarctica remembering all these past
got me thinking about
my own
experiences my own memories and how
my memories of past events are often
different to other people's memories of
that event
and i got looking into the science of it
and
realized that what we're doing when we
are accessing memories we're taking them
out we're
thinking about them experiencing them
when they go back they may be slightly
altered
and so over a period of time
we may have completely different
memories of an event and maybe we have a
family member who has been telling the
same story for 20 years and it's now
very different to the first story
they're told
[Music]
we wanted to tell the story about
power and the individual and
how
these big powers can affect our lives
but the more we worked on this story the
more it became apparent this was a story
about the individual and the individual
choices we make and we realized
the most interesting thing and the most
important thing in our lives are all
those small emotional decisions we make
and the promises we make in life
[Music]
yeah i want to make people
think and feel something
and in south of circle we look at what
are the far-reaching consequences of
your childhood um and this is why i
think video games are a fascinating
media
south of the circle was a very emotional
game to create
it's an emotional game to play
and soon you'll be able to experience
this for yourself
on consoles and pc
stuff of the circle is the future for us
but it doesn't mean we forget about our
past for me as one of the creators it's
hard to believe that it's been almost
eight years since the release of this
war of mine and we've been pretty busy
during that time so let me introduce
pablo michovsky we'll tell you more
about it
this war of mine is an extraordinary
game about civilians in war trying to
survive the war released originally in
2014 on pc and final cut is the ultimate
version of the game released only a
month ago on current gen consoles
[Music]
the game is special on many layers
i mean it speaks about human dignity
in very inhuman times imagine being put
in a war-torn city where you have to
deal with lack of everything food
medication treatment
dealing with constant danger
in such horrible times it takes a lot of
cost and heavy effort to stay human and
this war of mine speaks exactly about it
this war of mine final cut has got a lot
of content comparing to the old gen
version a content inaudible in that one
new civilians new scenarios new
locations so practically the game is a
few times bigger comparing to the old
one
and i need to stress out that
in the game there is no tutorial and you
may ask why it's simple because in war
no one would tell you how to survive
since 2014
we've been constantly developing the
game adding new story-driven scenarios a
lot of free updates
a ton of content including even charity
content that was directed specifically
towards gathering funds for war child in
this case and lately we've organized the
nation for ukrainian red cross just by
selling the game and we amounted 1
million dollars almost
so actually this word of mine is a great
example that
a game can make a change
and be that way something more than just
a game
that's all we've got for you today and i
hope you like it and having an
opportunity to be here i would like to
thank you all for supporting level
episode for so many years because it's
thanks to you that we were able to
achieve so many great things and while
speaking about great things there's
actually one more to come and it's right
around the corner so be sure to follow
up eleven mysterious news in upcoming
days because you're gonna like it trust
me
hello i'm york tiddle and i'm the writer
and director of the last worker a
first-person narrative adventurer
centered around our struggle in an
increasingly automated world i'm ryan
bausfield at room wolfenwood and we're
bringing the last worker to pc console
and vr platforms in 2022. the last
worker puts you into the body the mind
and the seat of kurt the last human
worker at jungle fulfillment center one
the largest such facility on earth the
size of the sunken city of manhattan and
you've been there for 25 years you've
never made a single mistake which is why
you still have your job and that's why
everyone else has lost theirs it's easy
to marvel at the wonders of jungle but
remember
here at jungle time waits for no man you
can say that again it's easy to marvel
at the wonders of young stop
but of course you're not entirely alone
in the game there's skew your only
friend and cobot played by jason isaac
who you might know from harry potter
star trek discovery death of stalin
oliver dar olufsen zelda williams david
hewlett claire hope ashity and tommy
earl jenkins we've got an incredible
cast this area should be off limits
jungle there are no limits so you start
out doing the day-to-day work of curts
dispatching products you're uh keeping
up with the robots obviously this is not
a work simulator uh you shouldn't
contact by a group of activists called
spear they want you to kind of delve
deeper into the facility they want you
to take on this espionage we're calling
stealth light gameplay
where you do have to go to these zones
where you're not supposed to be and so
you've got to delve deeper picking up
tools and weapons later on to access
these areas so you're always going to
have that push and pull between the
activists and kurt's pride in his
day-to-day job don't worry she won't
hurt you
again
right
hoverbird i can't promise anything
it's historian world
rich with drama and even the occasional
moments of horror and a lot of comedy as
well
because it's important for us to
build a world that you actually want to
inhabit we wanted to make something that
is crafted with love and full of color
we have been working with nick mcmahon
the incredible comics legend and
co-creator of judge dredd on designing
these characters in the world with him
and i hope you will enjoy the very
unique look of our game and younger
nothing
the game is packed with so many
surprises and crazy cool moments we just
cannot wait for you to play it later
this year
[Music]
justin remember the frigidaire is red
you can't take your eyes off of it i
mean you don't have to ask me thrice you
know what signals is also looking slick
with its old school playstation textures
and gritty and smooth ominous style such
awesome like gritty games that's true to
loosen things up you guys don't have to
worry about staring at a crimson icebox
we've got some upbeat style arcade
titles coming at you let's shred right
into it shred it
[Music]
uh
so
[Music]
[Applause]
justin
justin what i'm trying to play witch and
whiz here
candy please put down the handheld i
have a really special surprise for you
okay you have my undivided attention now
good
good because next up we're going to go
back to the future and share some neo
retro games soon to be classics that
give you that old school funk that give
you that feeling we're going to start
out with our favorite heroes in a half
shell see what's happening with the
kickstarter symphony of the night indie
style darling and much more this better
be good oh it will be
[Music]
special delivery
strike
yes
[Music]
teamwork is the way
uh
[Music]
yes
the dragon stirs in the void and an
empire trembles
the rule of the magi lords is failing
where now
shall we place our faith
in the low cunning of the celtics
or in the golden dead
to whom we offer prayers
certainly not in the foul magical praxis
of witches and lay sorcerers
no
this is our punishment
we woke the
dragon and for us
there is no salvation
[Music]
so
go
[Music]
so
foreign
[Music]
so
you're right candice thank you so much
for crying chopping the handheld because
that was lit turtles in time was my
childhood right there can't wait for the
cowabunga collection shout out to
digital eclipse also bats is out now and
you can pre-order the physical edition
from limited run games i'm gonna pick up
all of those games when they are out of
the oven i am too coming up next are
some surprises that fall into our last
category but also add some new flex to
the rpg and strategy genre as well let's
menu dive into the next set of games
shall we we shall
welcome to wrestle quest the world's
first pro wrestling rpg and the
sweatiest game here at the gorilla
collective showcase i'm zach the head of
narrative here at mega cat studios
i'm andy i'm one of our senior designers
and we've got some content here to show
you that has never been seen before so
wrestle quest includes real world
wrestling legends like macho man randy
savage jeff jarrett jake the snake and
more these guys appeared as giant
statues across the world map with people
coming from all over to pay tribute to
these icons
these sites are also the starting point
for side quests themed around each
legend
here on screen machachu man and his
friends are at the end of one of these
quests they've been investigating a
strange cult of wrestle raiders that
worship the road warriors
after a chase with the mad max style
wasteland the quest comes to a head with
a wrestling match against hawken animal
on the back of a speeding big
so each of these side quests around the
real wrestling legends uh some of them
you'll help the wrestlers some of them
you'll end up fighting them like here
and no matter the outcome they're always
the key to the game's best
sometimes you'll get
iconic gear or outfits from the
wrestlers other times you'll be able to
summon them into battle
so
i know some rpgs will let you summon
dragons and monsters and whatnot but
only wrestle quest will let you summon
jake the snake to rip a ddt on your
enemies or in this case if you're able
to beat the road warriors you'll be able
to summon them to their doomsday device
andy what's your favorite thing about
the road warriors uh i love the fact
that they can put their mohawks together
to power up
they fit in to each other very nicely
it's important it's important to have
that type of signature
speaking of uh working together uh
andy's showing you some of our tag team
maneuvers here
muchacho man in toy box you'll be doing
a blockbuster
[Applause]
[Music]
there's a cast of 12 playable characters
in wrestle quest and there's different
combinations of tag team maneuvers and
even triple tipping between them so it's
one more way you can customize how you
play
at the bottom of the screen you'll see
the height meter this is an indication
of the crowds engagement and interest in
the fight if you come in and you just
spam the attack button they'll get bored
and that'll drain out and your enemies
will get stronger but if you approach
the battle with a little bit more
showmanship and creativity that'll fill
up and you start to get bonuses extra
damage
extra loot
better loot ap regeneration it's all
there
[Applause]
there's over 20 wrestling legends to see
in wrestle west
so we'll be excited for you to check
them all out when the game releases
later this year
thanks for checking it out guys
hey folks i'm buddy the community
manager for akupara games and today i'd
like to introduce you to the core
gameplay of zoetty our poker based
roguelike by dusk light games
in zoeti you've got all the ingredients
that make a core roguelike experience
you play as one of a few different
characters with their own unique play
styles as you know you fight your way
through a number of battles before
facing off against the boss and every
time you want to fight you get a reward
you get more powerful before you face
tougher challenges you know like
all of the stuff that makes for a good
roguelike experience
when we get into skills and abilities
that you're using to win those battles
though you know like that's when things
get a little spicy in zoeti you have a
limited number of skill slots and each
one is tied to a particular hand of
poker the rarer the hand the more
powerful the skill two pair is going to
be weaker than you know a straight flush
so in practice this is how it works at
the beginning of the fight you draw a
bunch of cards these are playing cards
and depending on the kinds of poker
hands you can create you can activate
those skills
if you have three of a kind in hand you
can activate the skill tied to three of
a kind so here i'm gonna activate
boundless battle spirit which buffs my
damage a bunch and then i'm gonna
activate it again and then i'm going to
hit a bunch of times with individual
strikes
when you win a battle in zoetty you
don't add more or different cards to
your deck that's always going to stay
the same instead you can add new skills
or level up your existing skills or
acquire different skills for slots that
you already have filled changing out
these skills allows you to really
customize your build and you're always
going to want you know a certain balance
of offense and defense which begs the
question you know do you want a powerful
defensive option something tied to a
straight or a full house or you know do
you want something that's a little bit
weaker but more readily available like a
single pair of cards that you know
you're gonna find that in basically
every hand that you draw
and all of this is affected by the
underlying statistics and modifiers of
the game you know so for instance hand
size or the number of cards you draw per
turn are statistics that you can invest
in you know you keep all of the cards
that you don't play on a turn which
means you can have 11 12 13 cards in
hand which gives you much better access
to some of your deeper more powerful
skills like something tied to a full
house or a straight
you can also increase the amount that
you draw per turn allowing you to just
kind of dump your hand every single turn
for maximum tempo and those are just two
examples there's plenty of cool complex
modifiers that you know you can pick up
to enable really interesting builds for
the game
anyway i think that's about as
complicated as i'm willing to get for
this video for now if you want to learn
more about zoetty i'd recommend
wishlisting us on steam since i'm gonna
be really showing off some of the deeper
more complex mechanics in the not too
distant future and you know that's
probably the best way to keep on top of
things i hope you have a really good
time checking out the awesome titles at
the gorilla collective and you know
otherwise i wish you the best of luck in
your travels cheers
[Music]
ah
ah you know kid
the world isn't all sunshine and
rainbows
if you want to be a hero here
just being good isn't enough
[Music]
because this world is ruled by greed
and greed is exactly what you need here
[Music]
so kill
and blow up
[Music]
and loot
anyone who stands in your way
[Music]
on the path to greatness
hello everyone i am nana moon and this
is key locker turn based cyberpunk
action
q locker is a turn turn-based tactical
wooden rpg taking place in a world
without music where you play as the
illegal singer volvo her twin brother
and hacker dealer and the dukebot
drummer rocket
we pick up with dealer and rocket
searching for bobo who has been taken by
the satellites the ultimate authorities
of saturn they have entered the droid
factory the domain of one of saturn's
satellites the lazdu but the way forward
is filled with dangerous force
the combat of key locker takes place on
a tactical route where every move must
be considered plan your actions
carefully as each attack comes with its
own field of damage
timing your attack is crucial for
survival as every perfect hit brings you
closer to victory and every miss closer
to that
some attacks will cause passive effects
to appear on the grids
by using the plug modifier the fabricant
has spawned an electrical feud on one of
the tiles recharging his ep every turn
unfortunately his life points are too
low to take advantage of this strategic
position
[Music]
luckily dealer has spent a long time
preparing for this moment holding keys
to increase his progress on the skill
tree the drives are no match for his
skill level
[Music]
rockets however was only recently given
combat capabilities and could do if an
upgrade
let's take a look at his q3 with the
keys we have received from combat
the skill tree has two branches
available and each different class gets
an unique one
you start at the top using keys to level
up the talents until it unlocks the next
one below it
talon 2 increases your stats let you add
unique modifiers to attacks add passive
abilities or unlock new gear for use
progressing far enough down the skew
tree will even let you cross your skew
tree with another class creating hybrid
classes more on that in the future
if you want to see more of key locker
head over to our steam page and make
sure to wish list and follow
who have a demo available there during
the summer of gaming so make sure to
check that out thank you
[Music]
foreign
hmm
wow justin wrestle quest looks fantastic
the nostalgia of those pixels brings me
right back to playing royal rumble with
my brother on the genesis i feel you it
also brings me back to some trauma
trauma trauma yeah you know my brother
recorded over all of my high school
cheerleading vhs tapes with episodes of
monday night wrong that is so ridic it
did and it gave me a really bad
relationship with wrestling but there's
something about russell quest that's
making me second guess that and i feel
like i should really let all of this go
you definitely should make that happen
you know what joey
i love you and i forgive you
now i can move on with my life
great breakthrough candace and now that
that's all over we can move on with our
lives and the rest of the show candy how
can we support these devs and their
games by the steam event page justin so
everybody be sure to check out the
gorilla collective 3 event page on steam
definitely support the devs check out
their games wish list them and all that
jazz for sure okay kids it's gc3 key
time here's the qr code take a picture
of it for some of your favorite awesome
gorilla collective games from the
developers and publishers representing
the gc
free keys you love them you see the qr
code take it first come first serve
boom up next on gc3 it is time for some
time for some action we are going to
share some indie titles that represent
tough in the action adventure department
so let's go
hello everyone i'm giacomomasi narrative
director at soulmate games and i'm here
to present to you our latest work patora
lost haven which will launch this fall
patora is a narrative action rpg where
every our protagonist will have to face
a cosmic journey and use their powers to
save her and what she loves making many
significant choices that will change the
destiny of the whole universe
harrell journey will take her to four
different worlds each representing one
of the natural elements the one we are
seeing right now is one the planet of
her which is composed of five completely
different areas that will feature a
scorching desert this eerie mountain a
mystical river infested by evil spirits
and so much more
we've had a lot of fun creating
intriguing characters with their own
cultures and customs alongside with
colorful and vibrant environments that
you get to explore in details thanks to
an in-game zoom all the planets that
everyone will visit during the game are
actually inspired by real places and
human cultures for example wuhav is
strongly based on chinese mythologies
and settings and this cute little lizard
that we see here is called uk he's from
the xia tribe and he's also a companion
that will help us in combat while we
uncover the secrets of this mysterious
world
speaking of fighting patura features two
different combat styles that revolves
around the main concept of the game
dualism
in her physical form every will be able
to use a sword to fight in melee while
in her mental form she'll be able to
throw projectiles at enemies switching
between them constantly during fight
allows the player to adapt to every
situation and change his strategy in a
split second this is important because
every enemy inside patora is divided
into three different variations physical
mental and hybrid so changing out combat
style constantly is essential to emerge
victorious
the nature switch mechanic is also used
to solve many puzzles for example this
one is a memory game that requires the
player to listen to a sequence of notes
and reproduce them with the help of
everyone's physical and mental powers
the narrative side of batura is also
based on duality and players will be
able to shape their own path thanks to
the karma system
during an adventure every will have to
make many difficult decisions and each
of them will have heavy consequences
that may lead to different outcomes and
endings
so are you ready to meet fascinating
creatures explore mysterious planets and
discover where your decisions will take
you
batora lost haven is coming on pcn
consoles this fall don't miss any of the
news and surprises related to batora
which listed right now on stage
as hilda delves deeper into the quest
for her lost father
she will encounter many dangers and
challenges in the city of afes
let us introduce you to one of the main
adversaries that hilda will have to
confront ulelia the prey famous for her
beautiful voice yolalia used to be the
most recognized singer during afe's
glorious golden age
but like so many others
ulelia would fall victim to the curse
that spread across the city a thousand
years ago
the famine brought on by the asterigos
changed her into something else
she turned to an evil cult the etheris
and dedicated herself to it
becoming a symbol by using her
reputation and voice to lure more people
to join the cult
the encounter starts with ulelia flying
around the top of the seats while
sending attacks like voice shock blasts
feather blades
and cyclones
occasionally she'll descend to the
ground to fight hilda herself with even
more dangerous claw and wing strikes
after some back and forth fights ulelia
would fly to the sky and use her voice
and feather blades to attack hilda again
and this time she even calls upon
several harpy minions to assist her
during this phase hilda must fight the
minions while watching out for ulya's
deadly attacks from above
once hilda has dealt with the minions
ulya will land again and this time with
despair as she will cause feather storms
to swoop around the amphitheater
this is when the battle culminates the
feather storms will continually fire
sharp blades as hell that cautiously
counters ulelia's onslaught in close
combat
in the end only the strongest will
survive
[Music]
we hope you enjoyed this preview and we
can't wait to share more about the world
of astarigus with you
[Music]
[Applause]
spells and secrets
huh
[Music]
a tranquil island was hidden from the
world
but one day
its shield vanished
the magical amri once gave life but now
corrupts it
and all creatures great and small are
being enslaved
can you save iknae island
embark on an enchanting adventure
explore a land of secrets
and befriend all kinds of animals
and use their talents to make new
discoveries
battle
enemies or just hang out
build your home
decorate it however you like
and help develop your hamlet
grow all kinds of crops on your farm
and craft everything you need
to thwart greedy pirates
repel monsters
and uncover mysteries
in time you can explore and restore
peace
to ikone island
a new earth lock adventure is about to
begin
iguanae island
coming soon on steam
[Music]
hold on
bobby
[Music]
oh
hey there
don't you love a fun upbeat platformer
in froggen you take control of renata
daughter of world famous archaeologists
and inventors
they didn't allow her to accompany them
to the dangerous ruins of the temple of
theels above and now with the help of
her trusty frogen she must save them and
prove that she's a capable explorer too
[Music]
jump zipline grab and throw
the frogen is not only your grappling
hook but also your best friend
with it you can reach over long gaps or
even activate a lever from afar
[Music]
face off against big bug bosses that
serve as the guardians between areas
they may look charming but they're
powerful foes
[Music]
collect all sorts of treasure including
hats you can swap your helmet with
gallery pictures
tons of metals and a full bestiary
[Music]
be on the lookout for jake he's a young
treasure hunter who'll stop at nothing
to get to the treasure before renata
whenever you find him the race is on
look around for hidden treasure and
alternate paths because every level is
full of surprises and optional
objectives
from lush jungles to stinky swamps snowy
mountain tops and lava filled shrines
the varied ruins ensure you'll need to
be prepared for anything
but above all else be prepared for lots
of fun in frogan
[Music]
i am loving all of the frog games
hopping around frog gun and a time of
frog island animal oh my god ridiculous
and amazing premises
yeah spells and secrets will definitely
have me showing off my magic touch but
torah so many solid titles okay kids
it's gc3 key time here is the qr code
take a snapshot of it for some awesome
games from developers and publishers
representing the gc gorilla collective
there's a limited time there's a limited
keys we're going to be popping these up
okay get it that's enough okay
y'all got your keys
boom
up next we're gonna put on our creative
caps and get back into strategy show off
some games that are focused on world
building narrative construction and
tending to your magnificent gardens
let's hop right in and go let's go
tragically
the human civilization has ended
said that the post-apocalypse has got to
be all dire in i am future you find
yourself on the roof in a sunken and
overgrown city once called cosmopolis
where nature rains now
[Music]
gather food to cook various delicious
dishes
build yourself a base that would work
seamlessly
disassemble the old house appliances to
create new stuff out of old parts
explore cosmopolis to find useful
resources and
[Music]
new friends
i did not expect to see a talking fridge
there
oh well
get away and start your life fresh in i
am future
coming to steam in 2022 wish list now
[Music]
welcome to flat eye a premier fuel
station and technological hub
as the manager of flat eye we're
entrusting you to provide unparalleled
customer service
let's explore the various modules you'll
be tasked with to outfit your station
you'll be able to unlock the new
technologies through the profits you
earn with excellent customer service so
be attentive
at the start your module list will be
limited but each new unit placed opens
up new menus of possibilities
take this toilet module you've installed
thanks to your diligent work stocking
shelves and promptly dealing with
customer purchases you now have enough
to upgrade it to a smart toilet we can
tell so much by analyzing whatever's
going down the drain
with this data we can now safely open a
doctor booth to provide sound medical
advice to patrons so they can have their
illnesses diagnosed and treated with
further ilife branded medical modules
in essence you have the most important
job in the world
flat eye making decisions for the
benefit of everyone
[Music]
do
dinner's ready
be there in just a second mark
aerosol
have to help us
save us
from her
[Music]
honey
so
[Music]
look at this justin another dead plant i
could definitely use some gardening tips
show nuff you do not have a green thumb
candy i know i think you know what
justin no more real plants from now on
i'm sticking to animal crossing and
garden in
now for our final segment we're gonna
touch your imagination with games that
tickle your soul and jiggle your mind
let's hop into some games that bring a
sense of awe wonder and give you all the
feels jiggle your mind though jiggle
your mind well let's get to jiggling
[Music]
so
it was a hot sunny day
fish died in the lake and birds stopped
singing
those who could escape to mars i ran
deep into the forest where she-wolf
raised me with her cubs
many moons later you returned
you hunted and played golf
one day i found one of you dead
so i put his helmet
from mars greetings all you martians out
there it's time for another round of
radio nostalgia from mars
[Music]
blue skies warm days the long-lost
summers about past on earth
will we ever return stay tuned for more
on that
[Music]
hey
hello toddler pop there taking us back
to the days of late stage capitalism at
its finest
child labor never sounded so sweet
[Music]
where
hey slug cats i'm buddy the community
manager for akupara games and today i'd
like to introduce you to the five new
playable slug cats coming in rain world
downpour our new expansion for rain
world coming soon if you haven't heard
about the downpour expansion for rain
world it's bringing a whole host of new
changes characters enemies areas and
more to the rain world experience but
the thing i really want to dig into
today are those five adorable new slug
cats they are the rivulet the
spearmaster the saint the gourmand and
the artificer
up first let's talk about the rivulet
this blue little guy has a ton of
advantages to living in the harsh
foreboding environment of brain world it
runs faster jumps higher and can breathe
underwater which means it can zip across
the map between rainstorms that's the
good news the bad news is one all that
running and swimming burns a ton of
calories two rivals hibernation cycles
are shorter than any other slug cat and
three it doesn't carry much food over
from day to day play the rivulet if you
want to be agile but don't mind stocking
up between storms if you're looking for
a little more aggression though maybe
the spearmaster will be for you this
spiky slug cat spawns spears which is a
tongue twister that i nailed on the
first try this is my first take
definitely not my fifth one out of its
tail which means that anytime you can
start stabbing spiders scavengers or
squid keda
the spearmaster drains one food for
every spear it lands on a target which
means it isn't all that interested in
the dangle fruits and slime mold that
other slug cats will need to sustain
themselves if you want to survive as
spearmaster you better be out for blood
play the spearmaster if you want to be
the predator hunting down prey and
aggressively thriving between
brainstorms but maybe you want the
opposite of that aggressive playstyle
well the saint much prefers to avoid
confrontations at all costs which even
includes using its long tongue to
grapple through areas of the world if
the rivulet is nimble in water the saint
is acrobatic in the air and you need to
use that aerial finesse to stay high
above the danger the saint won't even
touch a spear which can leave it a
little bit exposed to being hunted down
and devoured play the saint if you want
to deftly dodge your doom with your
acrobatic antics
okay there's so much more i want to talk
about but i only have like 30 seconds
left there's two more slippery slug cats
coming in rain world downpour and i
swear to god one of them is the cutest
thing you have seen in your life
you know the other is just kind of cute
honestly i'm saying that to be nice he's
pretty messed up looking you can go
watch an extended cut of this video
featuring them right now on youtube or
the rainworks steam page otherwise i
hope you have a great time at the
gorilla collective
cheers
[Music]
he
detention
[Music]
ohayo gozaimasu
what
[Music]
oh
candy my soul is genuinely tickled right
now those games were so wonderful so
many amazing games today it was really
incredible over 60 games it's crazy
thanks once again to our sponsors and
broadcasting partners for their support
playstation razer astro gaming tencent
our fellow devs and publishers 11-bit
akupara all in games assemble
entertainment aurora punks freedom
graffiti gravity games arise hero craft
modern wolf raw fury tiny build and
wired productions also we cannot forget
our broadcasting partners twitch
gamespot valve and ign for their support
much gratitude you guys a final reminder
to be sure to check out the gorilla
collective event page on steam
definitely check out those games wish
list the games and support them on every
platform huge shout out and thanks to
wilmer sound we are here in berkeley
california in the awesome studio and the
scrappy illustrious mix team as well as
av society be sure to tune in on monday
at 1pm pacific and 4pm eastern where the
gorilla collective gaming greatness will
continue with gc 3.5 also you can follow
the gorilla collective on twitter at
gorilla collect and everywhere else at
gorilla collective as well as the mix in
the exchange on twitter and at media
indie exchange everywhere else once
again i am your host justin woodward
from the mix with my lovely co-host
candace mckinney thank you again justin
today was so amazing i really appreciate
you having me here i just always have so
much fun with you guys
with that we are signing off and passing
it off to jenny windham aka kim chica to
jump into the warm and full-hearted
world of wholesome games with wholesome
direct we'll see you guys next time
we'll see you soon
peace
hey everyone and thank you so much candy
a huge congratulations to all of the
developers and to the gorilla collective
team for an incredible way to jumpstart
today's festivities my name is jenny
windham i'm with the wholesome games
organizing team and i'm excited to let
you know that the fun does not stop here
we are going to be coming right up next
with this year's wholesome direct
showcase an event highlighting titles
that are uplifting cozy and
compassionate so grab a snack go take a
quick stretch break and make sure you
stick around because we have lots of
games to show you and they're coming
right up
[Music]
wow
welcome to wholesome direct a
celebration of wholesome games i'm jenny
windham and i'm joined by my wonderful
co-hosts mary kish and josh blaken
sit back and relax as we show you
exclusive footage and announcements from
nearly 100 wholesome games
and don't forget if you see any games
that you love you're going to want to go
to wholesome games.com that way you can
learn more about them and you can find
out how to support those devs
alright let's get started
the wasteland is a desolate place
devoid of life
until
the first turbine is constructed
rivers flow once more
and nature's heart
begins to beat
then
it's time to recycle
and move on
along the tropical coastline
life thrives anew
parrots flit beneath the verdict canopy
while fish frolic in the abundant coral
reefs
a paradise of biodiversity
even in the most inhospitable of places
life finds a way
[Music]
[Applause]
we just need to give it a helping hand
this is terra nil
hello i'm eli and i'm one half of the
development team for a little bear chef
a game about a very small bear in a very
large kitchen who's trying to start his
own successful restaurant you're about
to watch our very first trailer so let's
get cooking
[Music]
so
hi i'm majo felix and i'm the composer
and co-director of melody c
hey i'm rich cervantes and i am the
sound designer and co-director of melody
hi my host van der angel pastel and
co-director of melody we're happy to
show you a small peak of our game melody
we hope you like it
in melody you follow the story of a
young kid's journey through beautiful
landscapes in search of inspiration
solve block-moving puzzles listen to
calm music and discover relaxing asmr
scenes in a stress-free exploration
adventure coming next year
[Music]
jack wants to return nature to its
former glory with the help of his trusty
axe and his animal friends
[Music]
slice through machinery slap some scents
into wasteful humans and work with wacky
women critters to thwart the sinister
clans of industrial giant evil works
[Music]
do
hi i'm louis durant developer of the
garden path maybe you recognize the game
from last year's wholesome direct the
garden path is a slice of life sim about
the joy of gardening designed to be
played in short moments time in the game
runs in concert to the real world and
the passing seasons bring with them new
stories errands as well as a living
garden that grows as you tend it the
garden path is releasing just later this
year on pc mac linux and nintendo switch
and if you're looking to explore the
garden early we're running a limited
access to the game on hio thanks and
enjoy the rest of the direct
[Music]
this is mika and the witch's mountain a
relaxing experience where you're an
aspiring witch help the townspeople by
carrying their packages and discover
hidden secrets while soaring freely on
your magic broom
you'll be enchanted by stories from the
locals and the colorful art style
time here has a way of flying by
hey there i'm lauren i'm colleen and
this is max we are making 30 births with
a team of friends there's a new demo on
steam if you want to give it a try and
now enjoy the trailer enjoy
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
[Music]
it's mail time
as a newly trained male scout put on
your pack grab those letters and deliver
them across grumble wood grove
since its appearance in last year's
wholesome snag
mail time has had a successful
kickstarter confirmed a switchport and
is debuting a new area here for the
first time
[Music]
in this very first gameplay trailer for
usagi shima we get a taste of the cozy
relaxing bunny collecting game
decorate an abandoned island and
discover and make friends with a variety
of cute curious bunnies
[Music]
[Applause]
we're just getting started but i'd like
to take a moment to mention our
collaboration with the galaxy fund
helping bring games from nothing to
something this is a prototype grant
focused on the early stages of
development for bipoc and queer creators
each creator is free to use the funds
however they want like staffing hardware
coaching legal fees child care or
therapy
we've partnered with the yeti to offer
two limited time wholesome direct
t-shirts celebrating today's event and
100 of the proceeds will go to the
galaxy fund this is one small but
impactful step that we can take to make
our industry a more inclusive space
where bold new ideas can flourish if
you'd like to learn more head over to
supportgalaxy.fun
and get your limited time shirts over at
the yeti.com
wholesome games
hello
i'm back again
i can't believe it's been a year since
we announced to walk with yaya at last
year's wholesome direct i've added lots
of new things to the game in the last
year and we have a brand new trailer for
the game check it out
check it out
[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Music]
play as an adorable chicken on an
adventure to find the answer to the
question which came first the chicken or
the egg
[Music]
[Laughter]
so
[Music]
free ride is an rpg that secretly a
personality test
[Music]
you'll never be judged in terms of good
or evil and you'll never know when
you're making decisions
ready to find out who you are
[Music]
hello everyone i'm baptist one of the
co-authors of how to say goodbye and
this is bruno
she's one of the many ghosts who will
help move forward in the afterlife
our upcoming narrative puzzle game talks
about grief and how to deal with it in a
kind and sensitive way we hope you'll
enjoy it
[Music]
oh
[Applause]
[Music]
you may remember this game from the
first ever wholesome direct back in 2020
calico is a silly and sweet day in the
life community sam the new possum update
adds a new and improved cooking game
with all sorts of mini games for the
different recipes
there's also wallpaper and rug
customization and new farm animals to
collect
[Music]
once upon a time there was a small
animal village where everyone lived in
peace and harmony
until the king suddenly disappeared
now it's up to you to help peep and his
friends find sir barrington
[Music]
[Applause]
explore an ever-changing board
game-sized world where each playthrough
is different
[Music]
use your ability strategically to
outplay and defeat both
[Applause]
meet cute characters and relax with your
friends at the campfire
[Music]
dinos
follow paper animal rpg now on
kickstarter and get notified when the
campaign launches in summer 2022
[Music]
oh
fall of porcupine is a unique story
adventure about an unhealthy healthcare
system
[Music]
not only is there a lot to discover in
the old hospital but also in the small
town itself
[Music]
the last clock winder is a vr puzzle
game set in a cozy sci-fi world
your mission is to repair the clock
tower an ancient haven for the world's
plants and seeds built into the trunk of
a colossal tree
use a pair of magical gloves to turn
every simple task into a looping
clockwork automaton
these clones can do everything you can
do from planting to storing to passing
items around
[Music]
hi this is anonymous penguin studio and
this is our game love group you can
follow us on ana tango studio on twitter
for more updates on our release but
until then goodbye and stay wholesome
[Music]
in lovebird you play as a heartbroken
bird ready to dip back into the dating
scene
impress your dates by flirting to the
rhythm of the music
sometimes you'll succeed
sometimes you won't
sometimes it gets a little awkward
your goal is to find your one true love
so keep swiping
welcome to the world of spirit swap
lo-fi beats to match 3-2 a joyful queer
game about friends thirst and figuring
out why so many spirits keep popping up
in your town it's an action puzzle game
with a focus on lovable characters
despite appearances the game can get
pretty intense but don't worry you'll
always be able to make it fit your mood
played a new limited time demo now on
steam featuring updated art music and
story moments and get ready to enjoy the
full game in 2023 thanks for watching
[Music]
coffee talk episode 2 hibiscus and
butterfly is the sequel to the hit
coffee brewing game coffee talk
[Music]
episode 2 will have new characters new
features and new drinks to serve to your
favorite patrons
[Music]
get your apron on and sharpen your
barista skills for 2023
[Music]
hello
and welcome to the musical world of
odara let me introduce you to our
protagonists
blue house
red house
and the yellow house
you can place them wherever you like
or even on top of each other
for every decision you make you'll get a
different rhythm or a different melody
and you'll be able to create your own
songs with it but enough words let's
listen to some music
[Music]
in froggen your grappling gun is a frog
and that frog is your best friend
[Music]
help renata save her parents in the
mysterious ruins
[Music]
my
build a garden grow plants for your
potions and spells and forage
friendships with the townsfolk and
garden witch life
[Music]
next time on a new episode of princess
farmer with the mystery solved everyone
is off to the island for a well-deserved
vacation
[Music]
[Applause]
now's the time to kick up their feet
relax and oh what's that
there's a shell matching tournament
[Music]
the first episode in a three-part story
the guardians beach break part 1
launches for free this summer
[Music]
for those just joining we'd like to
remind you about our collaboration with
the galaxy fund
equity begins at the leadership level
and sometimes those initial barriers are
the hardest to overcome
that's where the galaxy fund comes in
it's a prototype grant focused on the
early stages of development from bipod
and queer creators
we've partnered with the yeti to offer
two limited time wholesome direct
t-shirts celebrating today's event and
100 of the proceeds will go to
supporting the galaxy fund
this is one small but important step
that we can take towards making our
industry a more inclusive space where
bold new ideas can flourish
if you'd like to learn more you can
visit supportgalaxy.fund
and get your limited time t-shirts at
the yeti.com
wholesome games
hi we are smarter club
last year we released teacup a wholesome
adventure game about a t-114 william for
airs in the forest this year we're happy
to share with you a teaser trailer for
our new game bubblegum galaxy
a chill building strategy game about
rebuilding the universe style by time
please enjoy
[Music]
um
hello everyone here comes niko will be
getting free dlc as part of the next
update
it'll be coming to both pc and nintendo
switch
we hope you look forward to exploring
gary's garden soon bye bye
[Music]
snufkin melody of moomin valley is a
musical adventure game about restoring
harmony and balance to moomin valley
protecting it from the industrious park
keeper
moomin was created by tovjanson in the
1940s and started out as a series of
books and comics
the stories are about an adventurous
family of movement roles living in a
lovely house with many interesting
friends
tovianson was not only a great writer
but also an amazing illustrator and
artist we want the game to look and feel
like something tova herself could have
envisioned
snufkin is our favorite character he's a
vagabond who's deeply connected with
nature
he enjoys his own company but is also
very fond of his best friend moomintroll
it's a cozy adventure with story music
and melancholic atmosphere as some of
its most important ingredients and a
tiny bit of mischief the game is set to
release on pc and console in 2023 and
you can wish list it on steam right now
[Music]
feed all monsters is a cute and cozy
line puzzle game
assist a team of delivery workers in
their quest to bring tasty food to all
the little monsters
find the optimal path for each worker in
order to get all the monsters fed
[Music]
oh
paper trail is a top-down puzzle
adventure about leaving home set in a
paper world
[Applause]
[Music]
you must fold and tear your way through
a diverse populated paper world
[Music]
solitaire is a relaxed roguelike story
game in which you can catch a glimpse of
the future via solitaire
[Music]
[Laughter]
the twist that lies in interpreting the
card's meaning and which future they
foretell
[Music]
um
the games and online harassment hotline
is a text message based anonymous and
confidential emotional support hotline
and it's created specifically for the
gaming community because we're gamers
and creators and we want to help each
other
so
how does it work
well you text us and we listen our
hotline is 100 anonymous we can talk
about anything you need to and only what
you want to
the games and online harassment hotline
is an inclusive resource for anyone no
matter how you identify if you feel that
you need emotional support you can start
right now by texting support to 23368
and our qualified responders will be
there to listen to you free of charge
reach out get help and let's make this
community a better place to work and
play
[Music]
[Applause]
a frog's tail is an rpg with a unique
battle system puzzles and platforming
challenges synced to the beat of the
music
[Music]
explore vivid locations meet a cast of
unforgettable animal characters
and uncover the secrets of the frog
goddess anura in this emotional journey
in freshly frosted you solve puzzles in
the world's most adorable donut factory
place conveyor belts to guide these
delicious donuts to their destinations
enjoy a dozen donut boxes each with
unique flavor mechanics and adorable
donuts
[Music]
out today on nintendo switch xbox
playstation steam and epic game store
colossal kaiju have appeared around the
world to bring an end to humanity
these kaiju aren't killers lucky they're
just looking for love
[Music]
so
connect with nature in this adorable
cottage core life sim about foraging
cooking and crafting
[Music]
live in harmony with nature while
learning real-life plant and mushroom
identification
[Music]
cook dishes and make herbal remedies
that you can sell at the local farmers
market
[Applause]
[Music]
customize your character and decorate
your home while making cute decorations
and upcycling furniture
[Music]
oh
okay
[Music]
in the grassland highlights the rural
life of the gaucho pampas and their
mysticisms
return to the land of your childhood
rebuild your family's ranch with your
friends cusco and alazo and experience
adventures in this fantastic universe of
gaucho culture
[Music]
bye
[Applause]
[Music]
hi wholesome i'm luca lead singer of ofk
this is debug
they are a cat
hologram and on monday june 13th we are
releasing a free demo of our music
biopic game at steam nexfest
we hope that our little story can be
something that you relate to
this is just us sharing our experience
that it is so hard
to just make something
and to share it with people
so many things get in the way like jobs
or heartbreak or losing a friend
so i guess
we are ofk is a story about the things
that get in the way
good and bad
see you monday at steam nexfest
moonbury's residents need healing and
you're the best chemist around
[Music]
with your trusty tools a brewing
cauldron and a canine companion at your
side you'll need to diagnose symptoms
gather ingredients brew potions and cure
ailments in this open-ended sim rpg
[Music]
jump from shadow to shadow in this
colorful beautifully animated world
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]
help other characters along your journey
as you seek to reunite with your human
counterpart
[Music]
hmm
um
in bilkin's folly plays take on the role
of treasure hunter percy bilkins and his
best friend drayton as they track down
percy's mother and grandfather lost
somewhere among a group of fictitious
caribbean islands in the late 1700s
over the course of their journey
abdullah will acquire a ship and visit
exotic locations discover a terrible
family secret and attempt to break the
curse of bilkin's folly before it's too
late for all this percy will build on a
relationship with his own dog and crew
and discover the true meaning of family
[Music]
[Applause]
ah
[Music]
fill the world with blocks
don't forget to clean up the mess
explore colorful and vibrant worlds in
this 3d platformer adventure around the
cosmos
[Music]
one last time we'd like to talk about
our collaboration with the galaxy fund
the galaxy fund is a prototype grant
focused on the earliest stages of game
development from bypoc and queer
creators
we've partnered with the yeti to offer
two limited time wholesome direct
t-shirts celebrating today's event and
100 of the proceeds go to supporting the
galaxy fund this is one small but
impactful step that we can take towards
making our industry a more inclusive
place where bold new ideas can flourish
if you'd like to learn more you can
visit supportgalaxy.fund
and get your limited time shirts at the
yeti.com
games
[Music]
welcome aboard tracks of thought
next stop the dining car
[Music]
here you can buy yummy snacks that will
help you on your journey
[Music]
your choices will shape the game giving
you personal challenges to overcome
[Music]
embrace yourself
play the demo on steam right now
[Music]
about controlling time with the power of
love
[Music]
but whenever i think about him it feels
like time slows down all around me i'll
have to toy with time solve puzzles and
progress
[Music]
you've been invited here to restore the
island alongside adorable creatures
known as critter crops in this 100
hand-drawn halloween themed farming sim
you'll play as sylvie a young witch who
is run out of her home due to her
newfound abilities invite outcasts to
stay in your town and protect your way
of life unlock magical spells to protect
yourself and your critters and restore
the island to its former glory
[Music]
hey everyone my name is lucy and i'm one
of the two devs behind the spirit and
the mouse today we wanted to share new
gameplay details with you your main
mission will be to find listen to and
help villagers in trouble around town
while exploring you will also find
collectibles hidden about
i heard when kiblin is willing to trade
them for upgrades
[Music]
to celebrate wholesome direct we
prepared the demo for you and it's
available right now we hope you will
enjoy it
[Music]
there's a lot to tidy up in a little to
the left
every day brings something new with the
daily tidy delivery
the daily tidy takes puzzles from the
game and gives them a special twist
with many variations of these puzzles
you'll get something different every day
unique to you
and you can earn fun badges too
[Music]
not that you don't already have your
paws full
hey there we're aesthetician labs as you
may have heard we were brought onto
kokopa's atlas to continue development
earlier this year in kokopa's atlas you
will embark on a grand journey to an
unknown planet since last year we've
been working hard to implement a
procedurally generated farm and crafting
adventure following our adorable
adventurers cocopa and palomaro we're
really excited about our vision for the
game and we hope that our new wholesome
direct exclusive demo will get you
excited too we'd love for you to check
it out and let us know what you think
the wandering village is a city building
simulation game on the back of a giant
creature called ombu
it's a game about symbiosis in which you
traverse a toxic world together
so take good care of boo
make sure to keep it happy and healthy
by feeding it and sending out your pets
regularly
and since andre is a good boy don't
forget the pets
and you will be rewarded with its trust
[Music]
lonesome village combines puzzle solving
and social sim elements to create
something completely unique
everything is wrapped in a fantasy
adventure with a deep intriguing story
and no combat
play is wes the coyote to help unravel
the calamity that befell the village
coming this year to steam nintendo
switch xbox one and xbox series x
it's almost time to say goodbye
but before we go we'd like to share even
more wholesome games with you coming out
this year and beyond
now these are gonna go pretty fast so
after the show you can visit
wholesomegames.com for more information
and links to all of these games
[Music]
oh
uh
[Music]
so
[Applause]
[Music]
do
[Applause]
[Music]
hmm
so
[Music]
[Applause]
and that brings us to the end of today's
program remember to visit
wholesomegames.com to find links to
every title featured in today's show it
would mean so much to us if you'd follow
and wish list all of these amazing games
and we'll see you again next year for
wholesome direct 2023 but before we go
here's one more game we hope you'll love
bye
hey
[Music]
so
bye
[Music]
so
[Applause]
[Music]
so
the perfect way to start the show
i'm melios and this is future play
direct summer's here and what better way
to spend it than turning up the heat
with the best the galaxy has to offer
let's get fired up
[Music]
so
i'm via martino i'll i'll text you
i have a good feeling about this
[Music]
you can't even imagine how busy i am
imagine a world on the brink of freedom
from colonial oppression
crime
class conflict
propaganda a familiar story hindered
only by those with plenty of time and
little to lose
detective myegan hill
the sleuth of agonoski
avoiding the past became second nature
dedicating her days to the faceless
rejected citizens of agamosky until mary
that is
this case goes way farther than the
banks of this one detective's little
neighborhood
[Music]
life is all missing kids and cheating
spouses until a dame from the upper
district barges in and changes your life
[Music]
who will chef rhubarb eliminate this
week text 10 free smells each month with
a one year family plan the government
said it plans to distribute artificial
snow to every household this winter on a
weekly basis
live from hillyanthis it's chef rhubarb
hello darlings
how much would you love to come on my
show and cook with me
[Music]
so
[Applause]
[Music]
meet the heroes of soundfall
melody
her sister bright
jackson
kai
and lydia
together they are the guardians of
harmony
melody is a lonely musician with
stagefright who protects symphonia from
the forces of discord with the
audioblade
a nimble weapon with a devastating spin
attack
jackson is an irresponsible but charming
metal guitarist who chops down
discordians with the powerful audio axe
and uses his experience as a concert
goer to stage dive to victory
lydia is a famously anti-social cello
superstar who attacks her enemies from
afar with the perfectly precise audio
bow and unleashes volleys of special
arrows to keep away the crowd
bright is a high-energy punk rocker
whose weapon of choice is the sturdy
audio shield which she uses to smash
discordians and create impenetrable
force fields to protect her friends
last but not least is kai a
perfectionist dj who slices and dices
discordions of all sizes with the
unstoppable audio side watch out
discordians that side is a long range
weapon
fight to the beat in soundfall available
now on steam and all major consoles
[Music]
uh
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Music]
oh
so
[Music]
spells and secrets
i'm all fired up and the only way it
could get any better is to hear from the
developers themselves
oh wait
let's do just that
[Music]
i am the co-creator of calico i'm
creative director of unpacking and i'm
the co-creator and art director of
button
[Music]
city if this even remotely looks like
your kind of game it is indeed your kind
of game you know what that is so true
you could tell if it's your vibe just by
looking at the colors this game is a mix
of animal crossing and stardew valley
except you can pick cats up and jiggle
jiggle we should put jiggle jiggle in
the marketing language i love when
things are unexpectedly gay i love that
too i am always surprised when that
happens and i'm like yes cried my eyes
out at the end 10 out of 10. oh i'm so
glad we got people to cry
like that's one of the big check boxes i
cried a few times toward the end like a
little bit not gonna lie i i actually
love watching people watch the credits i
just i love seeing if we managed to move
people so basically it's a game about
stealing cats and putting them in your
cafe sounds right i think it's a really
effective way to collect cats honestly i
found my cat in a bush so i was playing
button city a cute wholesome game and
then on day two the most hardcore metal
music blasts through my ears oh my god
you got the metal yoga we called it claw
core let me put the soy sauce in the
fridge i don't want room temperature soy
sauce oh no sorry we let you down if you
could open bridges you wouldn't be able
to put magnets on them sorry it was one
or the other no matter how much my horse
flips into the horizon i just can't
dislike this cute game
we keep trying to fix that got a
girlfriend in the game 10 out of 10.
congrats sherlock sherlock is their name
yeah i'm not just calling them sherlock
i'm just like 30 minutes in and i would
die for pedrams that's a common
sentiment i love this game so much that
even though i originally bought it on
the switch i bought it again on steam
just so i could positively review it oh
my god you are a game developer's dream
thank you so much we made this game for
you i am so glad that so many people
seem to be enjoying it that's just
that's our main goal and it's okay if
you cry you can tell us
was this like an actual like thumbs down
not recommended the soy sauce one yeah
oh my god
[Music]
oh
here we go
melly wow you look great is that 4k
hey baby
so what so what's the theme this time
huh are you are you still in space
i mean it looks like you're still in
space i can see your background
do you get tired of being up there i
mean it's not so bad i mean but then
again you get to see all the all the new
games in the galaxy have you had any
cool aliens are they making games too
it's so good to see you but i'm live and
in orbit for a short moment what's up oh
god i i couldn't resist giving you a
ring i got so many new things to tell
you about so tell me everything and give
me an update about what's going on on
your end of the galaxy oh boy okay here
comes here comes the ultra special just
for you sneak peek
i've been so so hard at work at pen pal
princess there's new animations new art
the same cute aesthetic that you are all
familiar with if you name it i
got it in store for you but that's not
all
i'm very very excited to announce our
brand new unreleased character our night
character look at her
big
beefy strong orc beats you up sends you
love i see her i see her and oh look at
those muscles i know and she can beat
you up or she can write you a letter and
personally like i'm kind of a fan of
both you know what i'm saying i'm like
you know you know what i mean i mean i
love a woman who can kick my ass
classic classic
well we're running out of time baby any
final words you make that sound so
ominous time's ticking baby okay um you
can find us on twitter at pep pal
princess you find me on twitter at
bellevue ten seconds uh
uh our kickstarter is coming really
really soon it's getting harder to hear
you um
and i love you
bye baby what
bb's the biggest ball of energy and i
love that about them
but now that we're alone let's dig into
some dark and dangerous games together
shall we
huh
[Music]
my
ba
[Music]
uh
so
[Music]
do
so
[Music]
remember this
measure twice
cut once
and tethers
are your friends
elsewhere
happens to the best of us
[Music]
bad move and boom
we're expendable none of us are safe oh
injury detected
please return to work
remember
the company is your family and we will
keep you safe
[Music]
we were sent here with a purpose but
we're not doing that anymore
[Music]
so
will you join me
everett
[Music]
i remember this place
but it isn't how i remember it
[Music]
oh i just need more time
i know i can remember
i
want to remember
[Music]
foreign
so
[Music]
i'm feeling refreshed so many amazing
games are coming this year let's propel
towards the future and get a taste of
what's to come get hyped with me
[Music]
uh
big
[Music]
oh
do
[Music]
i just don't know how to say goodbye
i love me
thanks for tuning in wherever you are if
you liked what you saw check out our
steam event that's going on right now
there you can pick up and wish list some
of the cosmic bangers that you saw
during the show
oh and don't forget to follow along with
us at heyglitch on tick-tock and twitter
for fresh posts and chaotic curations
don't want you missing out on the future
dear player
huh
oops gotta run i'll be seeing you in the
future until then emilio signing off
[Music]
take
five or whichever take it is take ten
take five okay i'm doing it
oh god you make that sound
[Music]
ominous
okay okay one more time
new art the same cutest thing that you
are what would that be
let me try
[Music]
there they go goodbye forever
welcome back to game spots coverage of
summer game fest 2022. you just got done
watching the wholesome direct i'm
curtain divina joined with me today is
davonte chisholm
yo yo the wholesome the wholesome man of
the day the most wholesome the most
wholesomeness of the of i'm you're
pretty awesome give you i'll give you a
hug i'll give you flowers another call
you out right
on stream that you're wearing yeah
you're just gonna jump right into it
that like if you could wear crocs with
the amount of you know wearing them
there they are crocs
there they are look at those i got i've
got a portal on there i got hey arnold i
got a game controller that's how you
know i'm a gamer that's how you know
you're a wholesome gamer yeah game
controller on it nothing says wholesome
and confident like just strutting into
the game spot office wearing crocs
covered jibbets yep
jibbets the other one has french fries
and batman and stuff but you know you
don't need to say that
and notice i took it off
and i didn't put my feet up here i'm
wearing socks but still we don't we
don't need me on like wiki feeders not
yet not yet not yet
anyways folks thanks for tuning in uh we
just we saw frogs wholesome direct gave
us frogs and who doesn't love frogs yes
and the theme the themes of this of this
weekend so far have been space horror
mm-hmm
and now frogs we saw multiple frog games
at hull and direct yeah you think it
would have been goats but you know we
already had a go yeah we only have one
yeah we can only have one go apparently
go simulator three yeah and there's
another spotlight yes yeah so we got
frogs space horror but uh today we have
a bunch of other things happening we
have future game show that's coming up
in just an hour on the future game show
if you don't know is a big old thing run
by games radar it's their flagship
digital showcase of games and this year
they're uh they're they're planning on
showing off 40 games including some from
publishers and developers like amnesia
amnesia
it's a developer i love that i can't say
their name they're the ones who did
creeks they're the ones who did
mechanerium big fan of what they do also
thunderful
uh which were responsible for publishing
last year's lost in random so which is
also on my list
boom
the ever-growing divide
it's a very long
scroll full of games movies tv shows
books too a little bit of books in there
as well just throw it all out start from
scratch
we have too much space horror and frogs
coming this year just throw it all out
and start there yeah but the space
horror isn't going to make it
the frogs will but the space horror
won't make it unless it's frog space
time will tell anyways folks but that's
coming up and so you should stick around
but for the next hour we're going to be
showing a bunch of content a bunch of
interviews that we're doing that we're
doing on the show floor uh over in l.a
with tamar hussein lucy james and a few
other guests the next one the next the
first interview for the day
is going to be hands-on impressions
of street fighter you play street
fighter
i lose at street fighter
so that's like a yes and then a no
because i don't touch it because of all
of my l's well guess what
i don't play it either which is why it's
going to be fantastic to hear
what tamora hussein who's a fighting boy
a street fighting man uh has to think
about it lucy jean is also going to be
there with him
so we're going to get to that in just a
moment but again just a reminder you're
watching gamespot thank you for being
here we're going to be doing coverage
all weekend i mean tomorrow big old xbox
day we have capcom on 2 on monday and
then a follow-up of xbox showcase on
tuesday so
keep sticking around keep being here in
the meantime i'm going to kick it over
to tamora hussein lucy james and their
hand on impressions of street fighter 6.
[Music]
street fighter 6 is playable here at
summer game first 2022 our key three as
time has so rightfully pointed out um we
have been on the show floor tam has just
put in a good hour uh on the game and
you've got your phone there yeah so i've
got i've got some notes that i want to
refer to just because i don't want to
get bullied in the qrts
by the fighting game people so as a
general overview of what we got to
experience first things first the
adventure single player mode is not
available to play um so none of the open
world stuff that we saw in the trailer
is is was testable um what i did get to
play was a bunch of rounds with someone
who works at capcom um four characters
were available ryu chundley
luke
and
what was the other guy's name
jamie thank you jan ochoa of
giantbomb.com um and my overall
impressions are i really really really
enjoyed it i'm sure as you can attest i
was very focused on the game i was going
at it with
with the other person playing with me i
think the the reason i enjoy it um it's
going to take a little bit of going back
to street fighter 5 and putting that
into context the main thing about street
fighter 5 which has come a long way um
over multiple multiple years and is a
much better game now than it was at
launch but the initial launch problems
beyond the technical stuff around
network issues is from a design
perspective it was very rigid there were
not a lot of defensive options
and it was almost like fighting game
players will call it a flow chart um at
the time people were calling it turn
based and what that means is you would
usually do a number of things and the
other person would wait and either the
the incoming attacks would work and
you'd have to respond to that or you'd
block and then once they were done you'd
have your goal it was kind of like a
very slow gamer chest but with far less
pieces and far less
room to move and the reason that was
that way was because you didn't have a
lot of options available to you
you don't have a lot of defensive
options and you don't have a lot of
offensive options
so
pretty much every
game at a high level played out in the
in the same way so that lack of
character freedom and player expression
kind of bogged the game down this game
immediately feels way more open you you
see more tools um and and like you've
got things it's been detailed a bunch so
forgive me if i
make any mistakes here but you've got
drive impact which is basically a
for for people who have familiarity with
street fighter street fighter 4
specifically it's a fully charged focus
attack um and that basically means that
you you kind of draw up a load of power
and then it absorbs an incoming attack
and if you land it it leaves them in a
crumpled state so then another player
can the player who's successful with it
can then follow up with more attacks the
good thing about that is is there's a
counter to it which is the other player
if they see the drive attack coming in
they can drive impact coming in they can
immediately initiate their one and it
becomes like a a kind of a game of like
uh out doing the other person um but you
kind of have to have an awareness around
you um there's also a drive parry which
for people who have seen evo moment 37
will know it's that kind of thing it's
not as strict it's not as strict on
timing as a third strike but it does
have that same kind of defensive option
available to you it's got a quite a lot
of frames of recovery so you won't be
like tapping forward to like do it you
have to hold down two buttons you can
you can tap them if you know that it's
going to be like an overhead coming like
a jumping overhead or you can hold it if
you feel like as a flurry of attacks but
obviously like it's there's an animation
to it it's very obvious when it's
happening so another player can bait it
out the interesting thing is if you do
that you can actually rush out of it
which is like a run and it's like almost
like a half screen run so a thing that i
was doing a lot was um
using the parry
in
at distances where it was very obvious
it wasn't gonna work so my opponent
thought oh he screwed this up but what i
was actually doing was trying to make
them think i screwed it up so that they
would start moving forward and then i
would rush out of it into throw range
and grab them so it was like a little
bit like of a meta game mind game and
obviously the other player realized i
started doing that too much and adjusted
and would like start baiting that out of
me um and then you have an overdrive arc
which is again for people with familiar
it's just an ex version so there's
certain moves that you can do that are
powered up like a hadouken you can press
it with two buttons and overdrive art
version um and it will it'll be more
powered up and then finally there's the
uh drive reversal which is a standard
just reversal attack um similar to
something like uh the alpha series or
the zero series um and that's a lot of
options available to you but importantly
it's all governed by a drive meter
um so each thing costs like between one
two maybe like three bars depending on
what you're doing and it kind of fills
up as you um over time as you like uh
play the game the interesting thing
about it is you have to be very careful
in managing it because if you use all of
it you enter a state that's called
burnout which is basically your
character is tired and they cannot do
any of that stuff so this is a period
where none of those uh kind of mechanics
are available to you and you have to
wait a sec time as you're like stamina
recovers so you have to be very careful
about how you're managing your meter um
which is where a lot of the strategy
comes in and it's where a lot of the
mind games are going to be able to come
in because you as a player can look at
your own kind of me and be like this is
what i can do the other player will be
looking at your meter being like these
are my the things that are threatened
threats to me and then you can do the
same to the other player
if you think of it as like a a painter
like you've got way more colors to work
with and you can create a much more
interesting vibrant picture out of it
the interesting thing about it is when
you're playing you feel like you're more
engaged you feel like you've got more to
think about in any moment but also
crucially when you're watching
there's way more excitement in watching
um obviously street fight is a big
esport it's a competitive game and over
time like street fighter 5 was not super
fun to watch because you knew exactly
what was going to happen and some would
argue here that just puts the kind of
emphasis on the player but even players
found themselves not being able to
express themselves you know punk played
the same as
justin with a certain character to a
degree um these now watching this stuff
it's much harder to predict what's going
to happen like good players eventually
will be able to like think about what
options are available and the likelihood
of it coming out but right now in the
early stages like it's harder to
kind of like predict it and see a flow
chart emerging um and that's incredibly
exciting uh ryu and chun li and they
have new moves that are like special
style moves that are given more like
range and options up close replays
really well i feel like in terms of
pacing it's somewhere between
uh four and five um in that it doesn't
feel the characters have a heft to them
um but they don't feel slow and bogged
down they can move around quite a lot i
think the most important thing though
beyond the gameplay mechanics is
it's like aesthetically really really
pleasing
there's a lot of like color there's a
vibrancy to it and it doesn't feel as
like
sterile if you know what i mean it as as
like a
355 looked nice but it was also very
like sterile and like it felt like a
very intentionally packaged game this
feels like it's got a vibe it's got an
aesthetic it's got a like a a a pomp
pomp and circumstance to like a bombast
to it um there's things like characters
walking in together and then fighting
they've got the soul calibur 2 thing
where it's like when your two characters
are facing each other you can move
directions and they all like have
different circumstances
they'll have different facial
expressions and like you can do that for
a bit there's like three different
taunts um everyone is like expressing
when they take a punch you can see them
grimacing and that kind of stuff the
music is really really like um uh kind
of like upbeat at times and there's a
kind of energy to it that feels really
good and it reminds me a lot of um
def defining quality that early capcom
games had like games like capcom versus
snk 2 it had a definite vibe to it
street fighter 4 had a vibe to it it had
like a
a theme running to it the idea of the
comeback when street fighter 4 was
released it was a comeback for that for
that game third strike had a hip-hop
jazz web to it this feels like it's got
a street fighting vibe where it feels
like a bunch of people out there in the
world fighting it's scrappy it feels
like you know it doesn't have like the
street fighter foul felt felt like
esports like everyone's in these like
arenas and there's like a like geared
like made purpose exactly this doesn't
feel like that it feels like a bunch of
weirdos for some reason are beating the
crap out of each other on the road
there's people and there's so much like
capcom kind of like uh
uh easter eggs in there as well there's
one point i was like is that poison is
that hondo is that like the mad gear
gang guy standing in the background and
i am very very excited to play more of
it like inside the lab monster in me was
like i just wanted i immediately said
can we go into practice more than they
were like no we can't do that yet it's
not functioning um and like i was just
desperate to keep getting playing more
and more and more uh and like yeah i
just want to sit down with it and spend
a lot of time with it and play more and
figure things out but so far so good
it's early days obviously take
everything with a grain of salt it's a
limited slice it's every all the usual
caveats for a preview i am high on
playing street fighter so maybe like a
few days from now i'd be like actually
maybe not but like as it stands in the
heat the moment you know i played it an
hour ago i'm very very optimistic about
getting something that at least as a
starting point is really really going to
be rewarding to play and hopefully
capcom continues to build on it um but
they have introduced me mechanics over
the over the time the street fighter
game has been out in the last few
iterations so
as a baseline street fighter 6 feels way
more interesting to me than three five
five and i'm i can't wait to play more
yeah and now unfortunately you do have
to go back and play three fight five yes
while you wait for six i think i'm just
gonna leave three five five like i'm
just gonna wait i'm just gonna wait for
the new one like i've had my have had my
time with it i'm going to make my piece
with it and just prepare myself for the
new the new generation mentality
mentally and physically i'm hitting the
road like ryu i'm going to take my socks
and shoes off walk that pavement with my
bare feet get real sweaty and wide
we're gonna have a bunch of gameplay of
street fighter 6 on gamespot.com
youtube.com gamespot so make sure to
stick around if you want to watch some
of that tam's probably going to do some
more stuff from 356 in the in the coming
days weeks uh so keep an eye peeled for
that as well and uh for everything else
to do with key three summer game first
keep a game spot
welcome back to game spots coverage of
summer game fest i'm current aveena i'm
joined with devonte chisholm yep if
you're just joining in we just watched
an interview or at least no more
hands-on impressions of street fighter 6
a game
i don't know i'm not gonna i don't play
i'm gonna try it he's going to play it
he's going to try it it looks like he
looks cool ryu's chest is nice it's big
his beard is cool his toes are something
to
feast upon
and i'm so excited for everyone who is
excited for street fighter 6.
um
so happy for you all yeah
tekken when you where are you soul
calibur
yeah soul calibur tekken those are both
things it's fine we can celebrate street
fighter we can celebrate uh ryu's chest
and his pecs yeah and that's it that's
all we can do yep splatter some paint
all over it because that's the aesthetic
they're going for
anyways thank you so much for being here
that was just uh we saw tomorrow hussein
who's like our street fighter dudaru
here in the office he got to be got i
think an hour uh
an hour time with it on the show floor
follow him on twitter at uh i think it's
just t
hussein tomorrow hussein look him up on
twitter because he's
tomorrow h to more h on twitter because
he's been
answering questions so if you have any
burning questions about uh whatever it
is that you want to know about street
fighter 6 he's the one to reach out to
he's doing a good job responding all
that jet everything other than the like
free roam stuff that way yes yes good
point good point uh but up next so for
the next you know for the next what time
is it
all right for the next 40 minutes we're
going to be going over a few hands-on
impressions interviews that we're
getting back from summer game festival
hussein lucy james and phil hornshaw and
a bunch of other folks at gamespot who
are able to go hands-on with stuff and
then but stick around because at 12 p.m
come back because that's when the future
game show happens which is apparently
we're gonna have somewhere around 40
games
that's a lot and some world premieres
beautiful beautiful love me some world
premieres will they be in space
most likely frogs and space horror most
likely the themes of summer game
festival
that said but next up is midnight suns
we've seen we've seen some we've i
haven't really seen any gameplay but
we've seen a lot of trailers we've seen
a lot of cg we've heard a lot of yeah
from james hatfield um and devonta
that's about it great metallica
i've listened to a lot of metallica over
the years so you know give give me
metallica in midnight sons and i'll i'll
definitely pick it up
is it so is it it's more metallica than
marvel
uh in this situation yeah yeah
until i until like we we see you know or
i get my hands on it or something yeah
it's just it's just
yeah
all right uh so we're gonna go over to
uh actually hands on with the game with
four with phil hornshaw midnight sons
but stick around
right after see ya
[Music]
the team behind marvel's midnight sons
are best known for xcom the stellar
tactical strategy series about sending
squads of elite soldiers against an
invading alien force and often watching
those soldiers die horrifically the
logical pitch for midnight suns then is
x-com but with superheroes but in fact
the new marvel title from developer
faraxis games is much more rpg than
strategy game this isn't another x-com
it's something very different as for
raxis notes midnight sons focuses on
some of the more spooky elements of the
marvel universe including its more
arcane heroes the initial premise is
pretty standard the evil military group
hydra uses some occult weirdness to
resurrect a supervillain named lilith
the mother of demons and starts aiding
her and taking over the world to combat
that threat characters like doctor
strange and iron man band together with
more supernaturally inclined folks from
around the marvel universe such as blade
ghost rider and magic included in that
group is the hunter a fully customizable
character you create who is also
lilith's child and the chosen one who
can stop her once and for all but first
let's talk about midnight sun's approach
to tactical combat back when it first
started showing off the game paraxis
revealed that it uses card-based deck
building mechanics for its battle system
each character in your combat team of
three has a handful of cards that
represent their abilities and when you
start your turn in a battle you draw a
hand of random cards you can play a set
number of cards per turn so which ones
you draw determine what your characters
can do it's a system that seems
drastically different from the tactical
approach that xcom players are used to
in the xcom games each character you use
has a set of actions or abilities they
can use each turn but each of those
abilities has a percentage attached to
it that tells you its chances of hitting
or missing as creative director jake
solomon explained during our play
session though the idea of characters
missing their attacks or their attacks
having a chance to do low damage broke
the fantasy of controlling an awesome
superhero team but some degree of
randomness is essential for making
tactical games fun and unpredictable
faraxis solution was to move that
randomness to character abilities
forcing you to think carefully about
which cards to play when and in what
order to maximize your team's
effectiveness your abilities come with a
lot of caveats and additional effects
making team synergy and careful planning
extremely important for instance some
attack cards come with the knockback
effect where the enemy you hit can be
sent flying if you crash them into an
object you can deal extra damage send
them into another character and you can
hurt them both quick attacks give you an
extra card play in your turn if you kill
the enemy you're attacking since you can
only play three cards in a turn having
quick cards can extend your actions
significantly you also need to think
about which enemies you target since
your cards will automatically move your
characters around the battlefield which
is sometimes essential to keeping them
out of harm's way from a coming attack
or effect playing cards also builds up a
resource called heroism which is another
key element of your planning your more
powerful cards require you to spend
heroism to use them so you want to build
up your stock for those big moments
where you can do things like drive ghost
riders bike through multiple enemies or
bombard the battlefield with iron man's
missiles but you can also use heroism
without cards spending heroism can allow
your characters to interact with the
environment like throwing a rock at an
enemy or blowing up an explosive barrel
if you've got enough heroism the
environment can give you what are
essentially additional attack
opportunities it all works together to
create a different tactical feel from
xcom thinking through your options and
abilities is often about clearing out as
many enemies as you can in one go or
knocking out the enemies focusing their
attacks on one of your squad members in
order to reduce the amount of damage
they'll take next turn you need to think
about controlling your positioning
clearing out important enemy threats
building heroism to execute big
abilities and more it creates a puzzle
that is similar to xcom but also feels
completely different in the moment the
card system introduces randomness into
battles that makes them feel variable
and interesting decks are relatively
small and easily tuned and you have the
opportunity to redraw specific cards
each turn so you never feel like you're
getting beaten by a bad hand from the
rng the characters you bring into fights
also add a lot of variety to your
tactical considerations because of their
different abilities and roles blade for
instance is a damage focused character
great for taking out tough enemies
because he can inflict the bleed status
effect that causes them to lose health
over time doctor strange can boost his
teammates and in so doing his attacks
become more powerful you can also adjust
each character's deck as you earn more
cards through midnight sun's crafting
system allowing you to focus on specific
aspects of their abilities but each
character's deck never has more than
about eight cards in it so it never gets
too complicated
phyraxis also made a big deal of the
hunter the hunter has a variety of
abilities that span from straight damage
dealing to support and healing as well
as an alignment meter that ranges from
light to dark the hunter's alignment
changes depending on the cards you play
support cards tend to be light damage
cards tend to be dark which changes
their effectiveness so the character
reacts to how you tune your hunter's
deck and according to your playstyle
becoming more powerful in your dedicated
area and if you choose to generalize
taking on abilities from all over the
spectrum your alignment reflects that
too the alignment system isn't just
about battles and cards though it's an
rpg system that keeps track of your
choices and dialogue as you work through
the story and interact with members of
your team as the hunter and there's a
surprisingly huge amount of dialogue to
work with midnight suns tracks the flow
of time in a way that's similar to xcom
limiting the actions you can take during
each in-game day at the start of a day
you wake up in the abbey the midnight
sun's base of operations where you can
run around having conversations with
characters chasing down collectibles and
advancing story beats and interacting
with the crafting system that can earn
you new cards at some point you'll
eventually pick a combat mission to take
on the further in the game you get like
xcom the more missions become available
and you can choose to take on key story
battles or go after more generic ones
that offer resources you might need
after your mission for the day you
return to the abbey at night where more
story unfolds in fact a huge part of the
five hours we played were dedicated to
walking around as the hunter in the
abbey learning about the various
elements of the game there are a lot of
tutorials strung together as part of the
narrative in the early part of the game
as midnight suns gives you the lowdown
on combat dialogue mechanics team
building elements such as training to
boost your card's effectiveness crafting
and more but the game doesn't seem to
have more systems than you'd expect from
say the base building side of xcom what
was surprising was how much of those
tutorials are built into the
storytelling and character interaction
during the session solomon said that the
midnight sun's team kept finding that
they wanted to spend more time with the
characters the draw for them was as much
about the personalities of the
superheroes and their friendships and
rivalries as it was about using them in
battle alongside conversations you can
have with characters as the story
progresses which come with a variety of
dialogue options the nighttime portions
of each day give you opportunities to
hang out with one specific character all
that time with your team plays into the
friendship system which allows you to
unlock better ability cards and more
synergy with your teammates based on how
close your relationship with them is it
incentivizes hanging around with the
other superheroes as well as learning
about them blade for instance isn't a
fan of your snarky jokes while magic
appreciates it if you can relate to the
darker elements of her past phyraxis
said the dialogue options won't change
the flow of the narrative but it
definitely will affect your
relationships with different characters
and you can only choose one character to
hang out with for a given day so your
choices for dealing with other
characters affect both how your
particular story plays out as you learn
more about each person and some heroes
more than others and how your team
functions in battle the tone feels a bit
more in line with something like the
avengers films or the guardians of the
galaxy with plenty of quips and humor
between the characters and tons of
references to the marvel universe tony
that's uh carol and dr spooky over there
here to help somewhat coincidentally the
game's story actually has a lot in
common with a recently released movie
doctor strange and the multiverse of
madness despite fibraxis beginning the
development of its tale some five years
ago expect to see a big cross section of
the marvel universe take part in the
game as well the portion we played
included missions with spider-man on the
team fighting a demonic version of venom
who had been possessed by lilith
marvel's midnight suns was surprising in
that while it looks a bit like the xcom
games it tends to feel drastically
different from them it's also a major
departure from phyraxis usual offerings
with an increased focus on storytelling
and rpg elements that go far beyond the
combat at its center but while midnight
suns is a little out of phyraxis
wheelhouse it was also fun to play its
battle system puts a big spin on the
underlying ideas of tactical turn-based
combat that also feels more approachable
than the slightly more hardcore focus of
xcom although we also saw that midnight
suns will offer a bunch of high
difficulty options so you can really
challenge yourself and its storytelling
though dense puts a lot of emphasis on a
group of deep and interesting characters
over the course of 60 hours it seems
there will be a whole lot to explore in
midnight suns and from what we've seen
so far uncovering secrets building
relationships and mastering combat
mechanics are going to be rewarding for
strategy and rpg fans alike how about i
take eddie here for his afternoon walk
don't worry doc that's just his way of
saying he cares
welcome back to game spots coverage of
summer game fest
2022. i'm current devina joined here
today is devonta chisholm devonte
devante
didn't have your muscle you're talking
about his mustache i don't know why
because i have a mustache yeah should
come up with a mustache ah maybe you
don't need to yeah i'll i'll think about
it the crocs were enough did blade have
i think blade had waited a mustache if
during halloween if i want to just be
blade for some reason then i'll you know
beard off just mustang black leather
jacket yeah black leather jacket that
those like chest piece sword thing oh
yeah
but speaking of blade
looks kind of cool i know this game
isn't going to be for everyone midnight
sons is definitely going to be
the type of thing that people look at
and go
you know like you know marvel's having
such a big moment right now still with
their movies and everything but i
i think this is this is gonna have a
really like strong like core audience
and
it's really it i don't know if it's
going to reach outside the thing that
the thing that i think is interesting
about what marvel's doing with games
right now i mentioned this a little bit
yesterday we just saw the preview we
just saw a hands-on preview uh with
midnight suns from our very own phil
hornshaw for those of you who are just
tuning in and uh the thing i think about
that marvel's doing
they're they're checking the marks you
know in terms of their genres right now
like we have true we have marvel
spider-man
open i mean it's i mean it's like you
know
tried and true kind of formula for
spider-man great game yes and then we
had guardians last year which is a much
more narrow story driven kind of like
you know work with a you still play as
one character but you're managing a team
using different things it's much more of
a brawler in a way uh and now for
midnight suns like they're going full
xcom they're going full
yeah team based strategy based so it's
like you have this they're doing they're
doing their job they're doing their due
diligence and being like okay we have
this audience we have this audience and
now we're gonna go for this audience
yeah i love how you uh feels almost like
you did it on purpose like you just was
like
not talking about avengers
i mean
everything is just like a dead game not
talking about avengers if i'm being
completely sincere
i'm sorry i just forgot i just uh let me
restart marvel's really hitting on all
the marks they got spider-man open world
action game they got guardians narrative
and then avengers live service game rest
in peace
you know people care about it there's
you know they added spider-man to that
last year right mm-hmm
yeah you would know that that's about it
yeah and then well so they got live
service and then they got midnight on so
it's like
thank you for reminding me of that
uh but midnight sons looks like you it's
xcom but it's not like and with a couple
i feel like yeah even with all the um cg
trailers that we've seen i just kind of
had this impression that we were getting
a camera that was further up and it
would have a very xcom feel to it and to
see the cards to see the camera much
lower and to be getting in as close as
we are and you know companion system and
all these type of like choices you're
making it looks like
yeah
i think it's gonna like i said before
it's gonna have its core audience it
will grab new people or like people who
maybe didn't connect with xcom that much
like me i played a little bit of it
liked it like naming the other like
soldiers names of my friends we've all
been there if we've played xcom and then
and then purposely just you know let
them all go yeah and they give them a
text like hey you just died in the game
sorry and you know have their reactions
you didn't try to save me it's just like
nah nah
put this all the thing is like midnight
suns looks for somebody who like i
really like
x-com games i really like that style
games uh but midnight sun certainly
looks much more approachable in the
sense that like it seems like they're
really doing a good or at least from
what i see it looks like they're they're
trying to make it a point to have like a
strong narrative and like something that
you know you could like wander around
you create your own character you create
your own hero yeah um and then you work
alongside these other cool dudes uh from
the marvel universe yeah including blade
number one cool dude yeah and i i i know
they're like sticking to some of the
like the some more supernatural
characters in the marvel years it's cool
there's just something about that
gameplay that i really want to just play
as wolverine
so if they can slide him in there
metallica some dlc yeah
exactly exactly let's get it
so much excitement yeah that's a really
cool thing too it's actually uh it's
good to see marvel leaning into the
magic
sphere of what they do because i always
felt like a you know marvel has always
played it somewhat safe you know
boy bit by spider
man affected by radiation mad man he
gets mad yeah big green dude
rich make suit armor man rich makes sue
armor but now we you know doctor strange
more is more in the uh is the center of
the marvel universe we have scarlet
witch another like
it's good to see marvel good job you're
do you're going to the fantasy side of
it
proud of you the fun thing i think like
the the comparison i'm making in my mind
right now is you're saying like marvel
is trying to
capitalize on different genres um for
their games and like you said that and
it i see that connection with star wars
too like the other disney property where
it's just like they're spreading
projects out to so many different
developers to hit those different
genres of games and cover their bases of
just being like oh you don't like this
well you're gonna like this one instead
something for you there's gonna be
something there for you there's no star
wars fighting game though right uh there
was one on the ps1 back in the day i
mean way back in the day we're due for
another one i guess just remaster that
one i remember being
what
yeah that guy if you can't hear him john
looks
he's the voice of god he's the person
who's controlling all these cameras he
knows about it he knows it's good
he says it's terrible but i say bring it
back okay what do you have to lose
i guess nothing everyone's mad all the
time star wars fans are mad all the time
you don't give them something that'll
you know
make them mad again you're not gonna win
or just put it on the revamped ps plus
and then like just temperature check you
know how many people
play it download it you know if that was
the only if that was the only game they
put on that ps4 ps1 game
i'm sign me up i'll play that for i'll
download it play it for a total 10
minutes you're gonna be the main reason
that they remake it hey
i wanna check it out don't don't do it
because of me
i'm not your i'm not your fan base
anyways that said uh
if you're tuning in this is gamespot
we're covering summer game fest 2022 all
weekend
even maybe even monday we got capcom we
got more xbox on tuesday
uh but coming up next we have another
hands-on with lego
brawl lego brawl uh phil hornshaw who
just did the preview of midnight suns is
joining us again with randy our very own
randy editor-in-chief gamespot to talk
about lego brawl but stick around
because right after that we have the
future game show where we're supposedly
going to be seeing 40-some games some
world premieres
there's a lot to see future game show is
great so be sure to stick around for
that and then afterwards because devonte
chisholm are going to high five and talk
about stuff yeah
a lot of stuff
all right
lego brawl here you go
stay tuned folks
[Music]
hey everyone welcome back to gamespot's
coverage of summer game fest 2022.
i'm here with gamespot's own phil
hornshaw and you just played lego brawls
it did it's actually been out of mobile
for a while though right but you played
the the ps5 version yeah so yeah this is
the bigger port uh over to ps5
and yeah it's pretty cool it's a four on
four like
combat it's it's sort of similar to a
fighting game like a smash brothers but
the idea is a little more cooperative a
lot of the time so you're like on a team
of four against another team of four
doing things like capturing a control
point and stuff like that okay so you
mentioned smash brothers there and i
think that's what everyone has in their
head that this is basically the lego
version of smash brothers so
in what way is it like smash brothers so
it's a fairly light combat platform race
game right yeah it's mostly uh like a
pretty chill melee game you know you've
got like a standard weapon that you
carry around it could be a sword or a
plunger or you know any of a half dozen
other or a million actually much more
like a million other lego things but
they all just kind of bash people um
and then you are able to find items like
you would in smash brothers or like item
boxes and you can open those up and they
give you one of three i think different
tiers of item which you set ahead of
time as part of your loadout so you've
got like a light item that might be like
a lasso you could use to like
freeze up another player and pummel them
for a minute um or you might get like a
medium one which was uh for me it was
like a a food truck that shot sausages
and could run people over okay and then
your third one is uh
something even more powerful these all
have armor too if it's like vehicles
that have like their own health bar
and then the third one i got was a
dragon who could fly and shoot fireballs
and they're like you know limited time
you only get them for a few seconds they
can get bashed on and you could lose
them um but that's kind of the gist is
that you're trying to get these items to
sort of overwhelm the other team for a
second but it's very back and forth kind
of chaos so it's like an assist in smash
bros i'm finding it very hard to picture
the hot dog truck so hopefully we have
footage that's going over this as we
speak
you know it looks like if you built a
truck out of lego it's
what it looks like but it shoots
sausages i don't know it's weird it's
all stuff from a bunch of different lego
sets uh they've got you know years and
years of lego stuff in here like ninjago
jurassic park but then more generic
stuff that is like the lego ip like
castle
and the way it works is you like as
you're playing alone you pick a theme
that you want to work on of like a lego
set and then as you play you're kind of
leveling up
and unlocking more of that stuff it's
all custom customization and like a few
of those loadout
loadout items sorry that you can use and
bring into battle but most of it is just
like cosmetic stuff to
kind of go crazy and make your little
guy for when you get into a fight and
you know make him a knight with clown
hair and
his space suit and all kinds of stuff
yeah
from what you described this does sound
like you know like all of the recent
lego games in which basically it's just
like a big genre mash-up of you know all
of the warner brothers properties so
is that the same thing there like
because i think you mentioned what a
million customizations feels like what
they're claiming no i it just seemed
like a whole whole ton of them um and
like just all kinds of stuff that you
might find in various lego sets you know
like you could fight people with the
sword or like alien stuff or a mop you
know all kinds of stuff like that and it
and like i mentioned the truck but there
are a bunch of other things too and they
things that might not seem like weapons
necessarily you know and but they're fun
to bring into the battlefield and just
kind of
rage around for a minute and then they
go away and so you've got it's a lot of
scrambling around trying to find your
next thing or bash people when you've
got a second you know with your whatever
you're carrying and what sort of ips did
they throw into this one because yeah
the lego games had all these really
amazing ips uh so i saw jurassic park
for sure and there's a lot of jurassic
park stuff ranging that entire series
from the original movie to the the
latest uh jurassic world movies um
ninjago stuff a lot of that as well i
don't know what else i didn't see any
like harry potter or anything else like
that so it doesn't seem like it's too
expensive on ip it's more i think
focused on
the variety of cool weird lego stuff
that's not necessarily tied to maybe
another franchise or something like that
like off camera you did mention to me
the open shirt ian malcolm
from jurassic park yeah
he's there also uh like john hammond and
you could bash people with his like
amber walking stick and stuff like that
so look one thing i want to go back to
like you mentioned at the start that
this is a lot more cooperative in nature
so explain that a little bit more so uh
there's like a
fighting the ai side which is
cooperative and you're like four on four
teams and so you're in a big map of
where you like might be a volcano kind
of place or a ghost filled haunted house
and running around these places are
little control points like you might see
in halo or gears of war and your idea is
that you want to take control of that
bash everybody else off of it hold that
down that's how you score points so it's
four on four in those cases and i think
you can play that uh maybe online with
other people and cooperate that way when
we played couch co-op that was a more
smash brothers-like
four-player free-for-all type fight and
it removed the control points and we
were just hitting each other um and
running around like picking up items and
the items were themed on the location
so they were very they were specific
like a crossbow that like made people
blow up in the
in the the lava level which also had
rising lava and going up and down and
stuff like that again like you might see
in a smash bros level um yeah so it's
it's
those two kinds of different experiences
it seems like but it's
you can do the more team-based fighting
or you can just go nuts like you would
expect to in a couch co-op game and do
you know that sort of chaos and i guess
we we keep mentioning the the customized
customization options in this game um
but as you mentioned it's all purely
cosmetic though right or do you stick
with a certain lego set and and build up
that set or is it just mainly to unlock
stuff and to look cool it seems like
it's too unlocked stuff to look cool and
you can look very cool what that was the
the thing that might have been the most
fun was creating your little guy to take
into a battle i made like a weird clown
with a cowboy
uh like cowboy clothes and he had a
horse
um on his chest like it was if he was
riding it you know but it was actually
just wearing it yeah um you they also
mentioned that you could like you know
that ian malcolm with his shirt open you
could take his head toss it on a
different body you can mix and match all
that stuff so the more you're unlocking
the more options you're getting to
making something weird and crazy
and
uh like our jordan had a character with
pom-poms and like a face tattoo and he
looked like a gnarly pirate but he was
also a cheerleader and stuff like that
and it's uh there are a lot of options
there and it seems like it like like i
said it pulls from the sort of like
generic uh lego world as well as the ip
driven one so there are
a lot of like weird ways you can
customize it
um and find like avenues you wouldn't
expect like like i said with the clown
was really my favorite for sure
but phil that's concerning that a clown
with cowboy clothes and a horse coming
out of his chest yeah sounds more like a
horror movie but this this this
definitely is more a
family focused game right so it's not
really a core fighter in any sense
i mean like your main attack is a melee
um you just have this like everybody
starts with a sword or a sword like
weapon mop or whatever and you're just
hitting people with that when you don't
have another item right so it's not like
you're doing combos it's not like you're
doing smash attacks it is a much more
like chill relaxed
uh sort of fighter it's more about
positioning a lot of platforming around
um you know tricking people and falling
into lava that sort of thing
and then when you do get those items
that's your chance to kind of like
rampage a little bit but you know you
uh for when you're facing that sort of
thing you want to get out of the way
you're trying to get out of the over to
the other side of the level or
out think how you can avoid that for the
limited time that it's going to be
chasing you around so yeah it's like
it's not going to go super high skill
ceiling or anything like that but there
is enough
uh sort of craziness going on that it's
pretty engaging anybody can i think pick
it up and have fun with it but you can
still like i still got beat by our guy
dave so
like
you know like there's definitely
something to it it's a competitive
element for sure but couch hijinks
family exactly friends okay uh phil do
we know when uh this game is coming out
and i know you played ps5 do we know the
other platforms that's coming out i
believe we have xbox switch and i want
to say pc and i think it's this month
all right thank you very much for that
phil that was our look at lego brawls
for more on summer game fest keep
itching the game spot
[Music]
welcome back to gamespot's coverage of
summer game fest
2022 we just saw a
impressions hands-off impressions of
lego brawls i'm here with kurt in avina
india my name is davonte chisholm
took it took it around with it did you
think of that it was good it was it
you just have this like does this very
like relax i always say it's like even
keel it's clean
thank you thank you it was good i try
you did good
davonte came up from new jersey to join
us here in san francisco
i love how you say up
over
i'm geographically enough i'm from the
east coast new jersey is like in mexico
or something
because you only got a way up in san
francisco always looking down that's not
true i've only been here for three years
i'm looking i'm looking at hills
constantly so i'm up and down and
everything like that that's something to
do folks uh if you're coming back as
davonte mentioned this is summer game
fest we're looking at we just looked at
lego brawls which i'm not really
i'm not really sure
entirely what that is it's another smash
like kind of kind of there's health bars
it's a lot more customization yeah
and
yeah
i mean i saw a lot of skins a lot of uh
legos a clown with a horse
so suspenders
uh they had like swords and stuff um
it's coming out this month i guess but
we have you know extended coverage of
that if you want to check that out but
coming up uh at 12 o'clock is that that
time yeah 12 o'clock in just a few about
10 minutes is going to be the future
game show future game show is a thing
that's uh ran by games radar
and they do this a few times a year but
this one's supposed to be a big one or
at least that's what they're they're
saying yes it's like 75 minutes long
they haven't told us to temper our
expectations
yeah no no they didn't go to they didn't
go to twitter like john keely like time
for your expectations no instead they
were like yeah we're showing 40 games
yeah yeah we have world premieres
like we got thunderful showing off
something we got a amnesia design and i
can't say i can never say i love their
games mechanerium creeks
fantastic i can't say they're the
camanita amanita amania design
take it up in the comments i'm not sure
i'll figure it out eventually but there
is something that's exciting that's
happening here for you specifically
the event is being hosted
by geralt and jennifer not from the
netflix show not henry cavill the voices
from the witcher 3 wild hunt oh
beautiful beautiful
can't wait to hear those voices see them
on stage and maybe may i know this is
this is reaching maybe
we we hear something about witcher 4
or whatever it's going to be called
maybe i don't know future game show that
game is way in the future they're on
stage they're talking i don't know game
shows talking about games of the future
i don't know
let me have my hopes let me put them way
up there in the air so i can fall down
and break a leg what would it need to be
would it just be a reminder that's being
made
yeah i don't know what it would need to
be um
maybe if doug is just like
i'm in it
you know like if he's just like what's
your best do your best your your best
impersonation oh that's uh
hmm
siri i don't know i was getting ready
for just you to get in a bathtub and put
your feet up yeah i should have i should
not say a word uh if you're trying to
think of any of his like lines of
dialogue that wouldn't have been just
like
his his classic f word or something that
could be thrown out
what
when oh well
wins alan or something like that i feel
like that's just just put on any gruff
like move over doug i've been smoking a
bunch voice and it's just boom you're
witcher you're batman you're anybody you
want to be at that point
and then somehow we're going to slip
back into james hadfield
if you're just joining us we've been for
some reason talking about metallica
because it was like all day today
it's like that's how like that's how
uh
that marvel game midnight songs has been
like they've barely showed gameplay so
recently we really haven't had a hands
on until recently so instead it's just
like look at this look at these sweet
dudes doing sweet stuff ooh
yeah master puppets
oh oh bingo
and also devonta is a big metallica fan
yeah a pretty big metallica fan but if
if if we could get there to future game
show and they can you know either one of
them can just be like yeah
jennifer is in the next one or geralt
will appear in the next one obviously
that can mean flashbacks or anything but
if they can just like kind of confirm
that they're working on it with cd
projekt red
there you go that's all i need i know
we're not at the gameplay
level or even like any type of vertical
slice or something but maybe even a
concept art i could i'll take that
because they're through the research
phase recently like like just earlier
this month late last month so if they
have like some type of concept art from
the pre-production they're doing
that'd be cool i mean i will say i think
that's a bit of uh
i mean i'm not gonna knock you down no
listen like i actually yeah don't knock
me down yet
let the future game show be the one to
knock me tell you to tell you the future
yeah let the people in the comments
knock me down and just be like what are
you crazy
don't
don't show anything don't make this
another cyberpunk devante why are you
rushing though i'm not i'm not relax
i mean uh
i
i mean summer i mean this the future
game show happens a few times a year
like they're gonna be planning on doing
it for i think gamescom too
they're always bringing cool guests so
it's not just you know like you know you
got your jennifer this year but last
time we had a lady demotress yeah the
duke from resident evil village and then
at some point before that we had troy
baker um laura bailey they're just they
had ashley burch at one point yep
they're just very good at getting in the
the all-stars the all-star video game
actors to come in and and and strut
their stuff all right well we'll break
the news everybody we're
we're going to be the host for the next
one future game show yeah we're the big
stars
yep exactly it happened we're the big
voices
in video games this year so be on the
lookout i'm gonna be
never mind i don't want the next
switcher anymore i'm going to be doing
full mocap
uh i'm going to be a sassy
raven-haired
lady
that's what that's what she is right
yeah you know black hair yeah that's
that's it lilac and gooseberry scent
just is that what they're coming off of
her body is that what it is yeah is that
in the game yeah that's in the game in
the books
gerald's just like
you smell like
oh
i like some berries
yeah it just you know that's just her
her thing that's her her smell you know
that's
we'll get girl that's what gets him
going you know
uh does anything get him going he's
always a grizzled
grizzled stone-faced man yeah but you
know like
he does have really good smells not to
get too deep into like whichever and
stuff you know but you know they're not
supposed to have human emotions but
listen geralt has some human emotions
all right
he he plays the dad character he loves
his you know fake daughter siri and he
loves himself
he loves himself some yennefer that's
another thing that's another theme if
you folks are tuning in if this is your
first time being here we've been
covering stuff all for the past couple
days we did summer game fest we saw more
of last of us we saw he's been he's he's
a he's a big glass of us fan mm-hmm he's
a big a plague tale fan yep he's a big
witcher fan yep and you just brought up
another thing girl his fake daughter
yeah you love games about people and
they're fake taking care of their fake
little ones yeah ish sort of yeah
because
they're actually they're blood related
so you know she's taking care of her
little brother
um but yeah i don't i don't know what it
is so
i'm just learning like wholesome the
wholesome direct is this he's just
directly very wholesome basically we saw
a lot of that today too the wholesome
direct
now uh
we're gonna do the future game show in
just about four minutes but i want you
to stick around after because we are
going to close out the show talk about
what we saw
maybe talk about uh
that beautiful voice the beautiful
voices of the people from witcher that
devante loved so much but then tomorrow
we should be coming back what time we
come back tomorrow it's early tomorrow
because at 10 a.m we have the xbox
bethesda showcase that's happening it's
supposed to run for 95 minutes
and then they're gonna have an extended
showcase on tuesday but also tomorrow on
sunday
right after that is a pc gaming showcase
as well which is also another big hefty
one so it's not over yet and myself
devonte lucy james and tamar hussein
will be joining all of us to ch
chattaroo and have speculate and see
what's coming let's see what we're going
to get a look at if we don't get the
witcher 4 today who knows
maybe tomorrow maybe tomorrow burst out
on the scene
they'd come through and just be like
xbox exclusive xbox oh wow how would you
feel about that
i mean hey i got an xbox screw it
got a steam deck in your pocket hey i
got a steam deck in my pocket you're
good i can play it on whatever you're
good you know what i mean you're good
exactly now we now i mentioned this
earlier but uh the one the only few
things we have confirmed for the future
game show uh is team 17 publisher uh we
also have thunderful thunderful uh is a
studio uh publisher that worked with us
the folks who put out lost in random
last year they're kind of like
thunderful is interesting they do they
have like kind of this like i would call
them like a good like double a game
space they like put out usually like you
know not full triple a big budget titles
but like they like they have a very
specific space they fill yeah and i
really like lawson random quite a bit
like i think lawson random had like
that's a that was a card based combat
system that like integrated like
card based into actual like real-time
action and like it was i don't know it
was really clever it was like kind of
like a sleeper hit in my opinion last
year so between that and inscription
like you're you're ready for midnight
songs but just like
but not like just don't say that
i just like i'm not that big into cards
but i just like lost and random is a
really good example of a game that like
you're getting did something interesting
with the card system
um and inscription was like you know
that game's an anomaly of whatever i
mean it's like half of a half of a card
game thing yeah uh and then becomes
something but it's really something else
entirely uh but thunderful like what i'm
trying to say is like they they feel
really kind of interesting space with
some of the stuff they do um and i'm
really interested to see what it is they
have in store and then of course there's
the developers behind creeks which is a
game that i absolutely loved i think it
came out 2020 it's a side-scrolling
platformer-ish kind of puzzle game
excellent soundtrack excellent vibe
they also did mechanerium mm-hmm did you
play those games no
add them to your list
this entire week we're growing less i've
brought all this cover this coverage
we've had
has been adding stuff yeah to his list
movieless gameless
lifeless lifeless yeah
um can we go back to team 17 really
quick yeah of course
there's one i didn't realize
they uh they had hands with uh you know
they were involved with massaging
autopsy simulators oh you know what
so uh actually i see that when i see a
little bit of that so that was actually
just revealed i think yesterday uh that
was an exclusive over at ign way to go
folks um and
that's actually this is i feel like
we're getting behind the scenes right
now a little bit because
we've i've been talking a lot about
forensics yeah uh
davonte's learned a lot about me and my
uh kind of my detective investigative
love
uh those sorts of games all sorts of
styles of things i'm the father i i
nurture people and when crimes happen
you're i'm the one who comes in comes
through yep i wanna i'm i'm the one i'm
the columba who comes in and be like
my wife's always telling me about this
autopsy simulator game
then you spill your coffee you take a
bite of your donut
i i am the grizzled i'm too old for this
i'm getting too old for this
dan glover leave the weapon all all of a
sudden
uh but yeah team 17 if we get to look
more at autopsy simulator that'd be cool
i mean that game looks a little
sensational in how it's handling uh uh
you know gruesome brutal murders i'd
rather just have it you know much more
um i gotta play it but i feel like how
they revealed that it came off a little
sensational and uh
leaning into the real stuff anyways we
got 10 seconds leading into that
folks thank you for being here this is
gamespot covering summer game fest 2022
that's devante chisholm current divina
stay right here after the future game
show
see you later
[Music]
ready to game the system
meet manner you slay you achieve you win
so should your bank account because your
power shouldn't stop when the game does
mana is the best gaming rewards debit
card where you can earn perks and points
by paying and playing and get rewarded
with the things you actually want like
that skin you can't wait to show off or
your next gear upgrade so why pay any
other way pay with mana pay with power
mana
game the system
[Music]
hello everybody i'm doug cockle though
you might know me best from cd projekt
red's beloved witcher trilogy where i
voice
the original bath taking monster slayer
geralt of rivia
now we've got a great show for you today
but i'm not hosting it alone
oh no
now i'd like to introduce you to
somebody who's been with geralt through
thick and thin
from mountains high to valley's low
and the occasional thatched roof
of course i'm referring to the
incomparable
gravity-defying
roach wait a second you thought that you
were hosting a video game showcase with
a horse
i was a little confused when they sent
me the brief but uh this actually makes
a lot more sense
lovely to see you again denise hello
everyone my name is denise gough and i
voice the powerful sorceress
yennefer or wengerberg in the witcher 3.
but today
this is the future game show powered by
mana
and we're going to treat you to over an
hour of exclusive trailers for upcoming
video games
and you'll be able to find and wish list
all of the games from today's show on
the future game show steam page and you
can head on over to gamesradar.com to
read more about them let's kick things
off with our first world premiere shall
we
[Applause]
so
[Music]
i came quietly
from the creation that we are most proud
of
that was outpost which is a working
title wishlist at the ready as it's
coming soon to pc
next up we've got a psychological horror
game that explores grief and loss in a
familiar environment
peggy
18. there's an old thing about this
place called hell where bad people go to
after the dead
has to die
but
the worst part about hell is not the
flames it's the hopelessness
[Music]
and i think that
is the parent of hell
that a person is
[Music]
uh
pluto is coming to playstation and pc in
2022.
now here's inflection games aaron flynn
to tell you more about the studio's
debut game nightingale
ever since the day the portal network
collapsed stranding us in these realms
we have searched for a way home
hello i'm aaron flynn ceo of inflection
games the developer of nightingale a
shared world survival crafting game set
in a rich gaslamp fantasy universe
you may have seen our latest gameplay
trailer during summer game fest live
this week in that footage we revealed
the realm card system a key mechanic in
our game that allows players to access
the portal network and explore the
magical fae realms
we wanted to take this opportunity today
to walk you through how the system works
in a little bit more detail as a realm
walker stranded in a mysterious and
deadly new world the realm cards are a
way to access other realms players craft
realm cards using magical materials they
find in the environment and those cards
are then used to activate portals which
will then connect you to one of the many
possible realms that exist in the fae
universe
each card has different properties like
modifiers that determine different
elements of the realm that players
connect to whether that's new
environments the types of creatures
weather patterns or how rich in a
particular resource around might be
players can combine multiple carts
expanding the possibilities of each new
destination
in creating the realm card system we not
only wanted to offer a way for players
to discover everything that the realms
have to offer but also empower players
with the ability to influence and
control the nature of the realms that
they explore
this paired with a sophisticated
procedural generation system makes the
possibilities for adventure across the
fey realms almost limitless
we love the choice this offers players
and no shortage of combinations to
experiment with and learn
will you find a realm overrun with
dangerous creatures or a tranquil place
where you can catch your breath
will it be filled with abundant natural
resources or will it be dark and
battered by storms where a lantern is
your only source of light we're so
excited to see how players explore all
the possibilities that realm cards have
to offer and what incredible new
destinations they may unlock on their
journey we hope this becomes a gateway
for players to discover endless
adventures within the world of
nightingale
thank you for your time for more
information on realm cards head to play
nightingale.com
if these shadows have offended
think but this
and all is mended
[Music]
that you should never trust portals
nightingale is coming to pc early access
in q4 2022
okay world premiere time here's the next
game from the team that brought you the
delightful co-op puzzler fogs
[Music]
that was trey racers which is coming to
pc and nintendo switch in 2023.
next up we have an update from our
friends at quality about their growing
lineup of pc and console games let's see
what they've got
product not yet rated
[Music]
so
[Applause]
[Music]
so
hmm
[Music]
that was your first look at wild mender
and robobeat what's next denise how
about an explosive roguelite where you
play as not one but four blade wielding
badasses i am sold
[Applause]
[Music]
more amazingly that was the work of just
one developer morbid metal is coming
soon to pc
you know doug i think golf is just too
relaxing these days it's like tee up hit
it onto the green get a hole in one all
that jazz it's just too easy i think i
have the perfect solution for you and it
involves disco balls and flying cars
[Music]
so
that was turbo golf racing which is
launching into early access on august
4th there's also a demo available right
now on steam and xbox so be sure to
check it out after the show
do you ever feel like you're being
watched doug
i mean we are on a live stream right now
i just feel like my whole life is being
directed
i wouldn't worry about it cue the sun
i mean run the trailer
now in its 55th season
american arcadia broadcast live 24 hours
a day seven days a week on every digital
platform
[Music]
trevor hills welcome to inax gemini
towers
you've been working with us for nine
years welcome to arcadia a very
futuristic city where all citizens enjoy
a life of luxury and comfort unaware
that they are being broadcast live 24 7.
arcadia is not an ordinary city but the
most watched media phenomenon on the
planet where a drop in popularity comes
at the highest cost
there
what
gus is
dead
what on earth
i need to get close to the cameras and
upload the loop footage from my cell
phone
but i have to be sure the right video is
uploaded to the right camera we tell the
story of two characters one of them is
living inside the
arcadia that is a city
where everything is perfect but it's
just a lie
trevor is just an average person living
a mundane life but the problem is since
he's living inside a tv show that is not
interesting for the audience it doesn't
make him popular the ratings
are not working
and the tv show
just wants to take rid of him so when he
realizes that everything was a lie his
life changes totally that's the moment
when he is going to escape
turn yourself in or you'll be
neutralized
[Music]
what we want to tell
is that students need to live just
for getting likes on
on instagram or on the social networks
just do the things that make you happy
and you don't need to care about what
the others think control subject on the
run on camera 4025 interrupt broadcast
immediately
[Music]
thanks to out of the blue games for that
exclusive insight into the dark side of
reality tv in american arcadia which is
coming soon
now if you've ever wondered what life
was like for optimus prime before he got
famous then our next trailer has all the
answers
[Music]
so
what's up doug oh my bad i was just
booking a trip to alaska a free gas
we're pleased to announce that a demo
for alaskan truck simulator is out now
and the game is coming to pc and
consoles in q4 2022
hello everybody i'm doug cockle though
you may know me best from cd projekt
red's beloved witcher trilogy wait why
are we back at the start i've just been
playing with this weird device that the
developers of our next game sent me want
me to press this other button and see
what it does no
no
let's just uh roll the trailer
[Music]
that's sorted anything else warning the
current temperature of earth is
approaching 100 million degrees celsius
oh great
puzzles are the most efficient way of
generating entropy energy
as an entropy center employee the
continued existence of this station and
earth depends on your energy
you have most generation
survived
[Applause]
thanks astra
[Music]
okay so
solve puzzle
brain hurts
generate energy
then rewind earth exactly
[Music]
cataclysm
that was the entropy center which is
coming to pc and consoles in 2022.
next up we've got a special presentation
from some incredible ukrainian
developers games development can be
challenging at the best of times and
with the ongoing conflict we wanted to
highlight and celebrate the incredible
work they continue to do let's take a
look
on february 24 at 5 00 am our cities
were bombed
the war drastically changed game
development during the first months of
war the work on the game was mostly
stopped
we sleep in shifts and regular air raid
alerts have made us move to our
apartments hallway pretty much
permanently
my teammates ruslan and xu have spent a
week inside harkin metro recovering from
never-ending airstrikes and had to reach
the city railway station by underground
tunnels to evacuate
[Music]
hey everyone i'm alex from weaseltoken
an indie duo based in kiev ukraine
our kind project is a peaceful puzzle
adventure called puzzles for clef the
story's premise is quite simple
following an invitation from your sister
a young bunny girl named clef travels to
the sky island of their ancestors to
participate in a huge treasure hunt
but of course there would be some
interesting tweets for those willing to
dig deeper
gameplay wise you'll get to explore the
island with tons of secrets all over the
place solve a variety of puzzles
different cute and whimsical locals from
time to time you'll also need to learn
and play some special melodies that
influence the world around you we would
really appreciate it if you followed
wizzle talking on social media twitter
instagram facebook please wishlist and
follow puzzles4class on steam that helps
a lot also join us on our discord server
we always enjoy talking to our fellow
gamers
hi
my name is vitali and i represent marvel
collective together we are working on
zero losses
a short open world driving game with
horror elements and hollow atmosphere
zero losses is our inevitable reaction
to the events surrounding us while most
games about war focus on action and
combat we wanted to bring a different
perspective filled with oppressive dark
atmosphere showcasing the unsettling
aftermath of the modern warfare you can
follow us on twitter and youtube look
for marvel collective
hi everyone i'm marginal act and i'm
working on this rainbow never and this
rainbow neverend is a noir adventure
detective when i click game about a cat
detective who tried to solve the murder
of ex-mayor of the sunny city and also
tries to solve the mystery of never
ending downpour can subscribe to my
social networks twitter instagram also
you can visualize this ray will never
end thank you very much glory to ukraine
hello world my name is andriy bchkowski
i'm indie game developer originally from
kiev together with a small team i'm
working on turn based mars colony city
builder called farlanders in my games
i'm always trying to make some unique
mechanics to stand out except for colony
building the core mechanic in the game
is terraforming also in the game you can
learn new technologies trade with other
colonies and explore underground caves
so to summarize if farlanders seems like
your cup of tea which listed on steam or
try out for landers prologue which is
already available for free
hi my name is albert conner i am the
developer of the indie games through the
nightmares there's nightmares is
hardcore platformer about sandman that
travels in the mysterious and
frightening world of the children
nightmares the player will have to
overcome all children's fears and fight
with the almighty god of james marthaus
if you want to support us visit our
steam page add the game to your wishlist
play the demo and give us your feedback
in any possible way
[Music]
head on over to gamesradar.com for more
information on our games for ukraine
presentation and a list of charities
that would welcome your support
if you like the animation series gravity
falls or over the garden wall you're
going to love our next game lost in play
is a puzzle adventure that follows two
siblings lost in their own imagination
[Music]
ah
lost in play lands on pc and nintendo
switch on august 10 2022
you know what we're approaching the
midpoint of the show and i could kill
for a nice refreshing drink
is there any redanian lager lying around
spoken like a true witcher
we don't have any real beer but this
next trailer is sure to quench your
thirst
[Music]
so
i think that's done the trick brewmaster
is coming to pc and consoles in 2022
with a demo available right now on steam
next let's check out an exclusive
trailer for bramble the mountain king a
puzzle platformer heavily inspired by
nordic folklore
hello everyone my name is eleanor and
i'm the lead artist at dim frost studio
and today i will introduce one of our
creatures that you'll meet on your
journey in bramble the mountain king a
grim adventure based on dark nordic
fables
meccan is just one of our favorite
creatures from nordic folklore found in
cautionary tales meant to scare children
from going too close to the water
in bramble meccan is a lonely creature
living in a lake luring people with his
music so enchantedly that they would
drown
in his past life he was just a simple
man who loved playing his violin
unfortunately
the village didn't appreciate his talent
and people would frequently bully him
the only soul that didn't
was a girl that neck and fell in love
with
one day
the bullying and beating became so
severe that nikken's anger finally
overtook him
he marched into the village playing
forbidden melodies that made everyone
dance until their flesh and bone got
worn down
they eventually died
leaving behind shuffling corpses still
trying to dance to nekken's melodies
his love wasn't spared death either
devastated naked left the town and lived
by the lake drowning in his sorrow
luring people with his deadly music
nekken is just one of the creatures
you'll meet in bramble the mountain king
you will meet many more both big and
small good and evil on your journey
throughout the beautiful yet deadly
world of bramble
bramble the mountain king is coming soon
to pc and consoles be sure to add
bramble to your wishlist thank you for
watching
[Music]
i know a necker when i see one bramble
the mountain king is coming soon to pc
and consoles
okay now i'm no mobster but i've got an
offer that you can refuse in the form of
a world premiere
the world has always been divided into
people with money
and those who want to get it at any cost
and in the middle of this conflict
are also those
who just fight on one side or the other
unknown heroes or villains
perhaps the right choices
can be written on the pages of one story
or another
the best way to get rich is sometimes
to get remembered
each single struggle
will be the fight for your life
as
enemy of the state
enemy of the state is coming to pc and
consoles in 2024.
now we've had so many amazing trailers
but i think it's time for a break
tea
coffee
hail oh i've got something better than
tea you just have to follow me through
one of my portals no need to be afraid
though we have done this before
this never ends well for me
oh my god where am i
it's so bright
and what's that smell
lilac and gooseberries ah no doug this
is the virtual show floor every booth in
here has a game attached with a demo
going live after the show google future
games show steam to find the dedicated
page and try out any of the games you
like the look of let's go just when you
thought you'd had enough of being
tarnished this year we've got a fantasy
rpg set in the ruins of two divine
kingdoms the tarnishing of juxta
features awesome boss battles high risk
high reward combat and a beautiful score
to boot it's also launching later this
year in summer 2022 what's next denise
from one ruined kingdom to another let's
take a look at the grimdark world of
orcs a blend of tower defense and deck
building gameplay orcs invites players
to fortify castles and expand their
territory while fighting against an
onslaught of you guessed it orcs with
over 300 cards and four factions to play
with orcs is coming to pc later this
year
over here we've got a point and click
inspired by the lucas arts classics
let's check in on a twisted tale with
hand-drawn backgrounds and a catalog of
comical characters this old school
adventure will have you giggling and
traveling to broken cities mighty pirate
ships deep jungles and more
inspired by games like slay the spire
and monster train here comes a rock and
roll roguelite where players use musical
abilities to fend off a mosh pit of
monsters this diverse deck builder is a
bonafide battle of the bands where you
assemble a team of vicious virtuosos to
defend against hordes of demons
reptilian rising is a turn-based tactics
game where you take on a barbaric horde
of lizards and futuristic robot
dinosaurs fighters from across time are
recreated in a retro miniature format in
a true homage to the tabletop style of
the 1980s reptilian rising features
multiple replayable levels with lots of
bonus objectives and you can also
challenge fellow players in online pvp
to see which tactician ends up on top
think less i am the danger and more i am
the savior potion permit is a cute
chemist simulator from masshive media
with rich pixel art and a soaring score
you'll gather ingredients to brew
precious remedies that help the
townsfolk of
pack your satchel because potion permit
is coming to pc and console in 2022
next up we've got a gorgeous rhythm game
set in a world where dreams and reality
collide melatonin from half asleep games
pits players in a pastel world where
they must unravel a narrative by
engaging in charming challenges
complemented by a bouncy vibrant score
next up we've got a musical adventure
about two best friends trying to make it
in the big city once upon a jester
follows jester and sock as they try to
develop a dynamic improvisational
theater show worthy of the royal
theatrical spectacle decide your genre
listen to the crowd and make valuable
friends in this hand-crafted lo-fi
odyssey
if you've ever wanted to play tag in a
graveyard full of ghouls then this game
is for you
bail or jail is a creepy cute
asymmetrical multiplayer game from
konami players have three minutes to
round up runaway humans or escape the
grasp of malevolent monsters each with
unique abilities and that's a wrap on
the virtual show floor remember to head
to the future games show steam page if
you want to play these beauties after
the show free of
charge
and just one final reminder that you can
google future games show steam to
download all those demos after the show
wins howling
i think that means there's another world
premiere on the horizon
peggy 18.
[Applause]
[Music]
ah
that was your first look at sunday gold
which is coming in 2022
our next game is coming to vr platforms
but i doubt you'll be able to keep your
fancy headsets on for too long when
you're playing let's take a look
foreign
is with no noise
julian
[Music]
i'll pick hide please do not open is
coming to vr platforms in fall 2022
now it's time for an update on bright
memory infinite fyqd studios hectic
shooter
shelia according to info from the front
lines general lynn's unit has arrived at
the scene general lynn the top dog in
sai
they say that tech wise even we here at
sro can't hold a candle to these guys
roger i'll move cautiously
it's been a while shelia
to think we'd meet like this
once it's all been poured out a new
world will be born
[Music]
[Applause]
but you're too late once i finish
pouring this primordial flood over earth
the black hole will change the world
shall we respond
what happened
shelia
[Music]
uh
bright memory infinite is out now on pc
and is coming soon to playstation xbox
and nintendo switch
next up we've got a gothic horror
metroidvania that looks like a pixely
version of bloodborne let's check it out
[Applause]
wrong
[Music]
hmm
ah
[Music]
so
the last faith is coming to pc and
consoles in 2022.
now let's check in with our friends from
team 17 who have a montage of exciting
upcoming games to show us
peggy 18.
[Music]
come on frank we need to vacate these
premises now
[Music]
let's move on straight to our deceased
well who do we have here today
[Music]
so
roses rose
now get off
[Music]
me
be sure to wish list any games that
stood out and you can read more about
them on gamesradar.com
have you ever wondered what the bugs in
your house are doing when you're out not
really probably just making a mess you'd
be surprised try complex governmental
structures and organized religion at
least that's the brief i've got for
tinykin which is up next
[Music]
welcome to the fascinating world of tiny
kid
are extraordinary little creatures
alone they rarely pose a threat
but in great numbers they are exemplary
look here's some now
ah the purple tiny kid
extremely powerful despite their small
stature
look here green tiny kid
extremely resourceful in reaching daring
new heights
[Music]
stand back
unless you want a blue tiny kin to zap
and that's everything
wait what's this
well look there's daniel a red tiny kid
adorable
with an immensely fiery tamper
[Music]
tinykin is coming to pc playstation xbox
and nintendo switch
you know when you're finished cleaning
but you realize you missed a bunch of
crumbs it's like just when i thought i
was out they pull me back in
yeah it's like when the boss orders a
hit and you've got to go clean it up
after hours yeah
sort of maybe this next game is for you
[Music]
four people
sharing the table
on a new year's eve
a plate full of troubling memories
[Music]
and a bitter taste of regrets
505 games and draw distance are proud to
present
serial cleaners
[Music]
a story of
loyalty
betrayal
and crime
lots of crime
the past they share
is all that stands in the way of
redemption
if you remember the 90s differently
their dirty work is the reason why
[Music]
ah
so that's how you get wine out of a
carpet cereal cleaners is launching in
september on pc nintendo switch
playstation and xbox
do you ever miss taking your shoes off
in front of strangers and spending your
life savings on a cup of coffee and boy
do we have the simulator for you
[Music]
[Applause]
don't forget to renew your passport
because airport simulator is coming in
to land on pc and xbox series x and s in
let's break things up with our wants to
watch montage keep your eyes peeled for
several exciting games that are coming
in the near future and check out this
awesome bespoke introduction from the
team behind in kulinati
[Music]
so
did any of those games turn your head
check out gamesradar.com for more
information
next up we've got a new game from the
minds behind happy game amanita design
in phonopolis you'll help felix solve
playful puzzles in an avant-garde
fiberboard city we couldn't quite work
out how either but what you're about to
see is actual gameplay
[Music]
that was funopolis which is coming soon
now we've got a subterranean roguelike
where you play as a lucid dreamer in a
world of endless slumber
please
please grant us protection from that
hideous strength
it casts a shadow as endless as the
dream
we all wither within its shade
succumbing to all manner of desire
willed into being by the dream
those who refuse to slay such corrupt
thirst
are cast into the depths to languish in
solitude
this dream is ours
you need only ask for what you desire to
will it into
[Music]
a lost land requires a shepherd what
manner of shepherd are you wolf
down here
the only one around
don't sleep on being and becoming which
is
becoming soon to pc
our next game follows a pilot who crash
lands in the arctic after his plane is
chopped in half by mysterious forces but
he also has a court-mandated therapy
robot called alfie every cloud right
hello kai i thought you could use some
company up here
yeah not really i'm good
[Music]
donovan
donovan you copy
hey drone
wake up
i must have unexpectedly powered
[Music]
you out there oh thank god i thought i'd
lost you
was that donovan i heard on the radio
what you're spying on me now
i got it
covered by some big ass solos
[Music]
wait power station
out here
hey donovan
donovan you copy
[Music]
no thermal vision no lasers no useful
functions whatsoever
can you do anything to actually help
i am happy to talk it through with you
uh doug it's your line again
oh sorry i'm just canceling that trip to
alaska that was arctic awakening which
is coming to pc mac and consoles in 2023
we've had a lot of fast paced games in
this showcase but none quite as quick as
our next trailer let's stay on track and
check this one out
this is not a challenge for the
faint-hearted where the 20 best drivers
in the world come together to take on
some of the world's most historic
circuits and that legacy continues today
it's lights out and away we go
just stay in the car
there's not much in it at the front with
the two cars constantly vying for first
place it's a thrilling battle with
neither driver giving an inch
[Applause]
we might still be early in the season
but that doesn't mean we can sit back
and relax everything is up for grabs and
nothing is certain at this stage
[Music]
here we go with the azerbaijan grand
prix
[Music]
think
we should be satisfied with
the step we've got at least here
oh no it's a spin
bitly
strap yourselves in this is formula one
who wants to be in the driver's seat
when you can be in the driver's driver's
seat anyway don't forget to tune into
the pc gaming show to see the first game
play from f1 manager which is racing
onto pc playstation and xbox on august
25th 2022.
put your dukes up folks because this
next game is a certified dko wait what
does that mean a divine knockout dog duh
[Music]
that was divine knockout which is coming
soon
our next game is an adventure epic where
you navigate a world full of tricky
puzzles with the help of your robo
friend it's true that behind every main
character there's a smart talented
companion to help them get through it
all denise
are you referring to yennefer well if
the shoe fits here's planet of lana
ima
hola muni
[Music]
yellow
hello
unlikely
[Music]
uh
planet of lana is coming to pc and xbox
in 2022
this next reveal is a pretty big deal no
spoilers but let's just say i really
didn't see this one coming
[Music]
our world contains phenomena that could
never be explained with logic
this changes everything
it's time to put our skills to the test
deadly premonition 2 is out now on pc
that's right now today this second
go check it out
based on the notes on my script it looks
like the producers were struggling for
jokes on this one there's something
about geralt hunting a moomin honestly
it's not even worth it this trailer is
adorable and i just need you all to see
it
[Music]
oh
uh
[Music]
oh
stuffkin melody of moomin valley is
coming to pc and consoles in 2023 with a
soundtrack from icelandic post rock band
sigur ross
last but not least we've got a brand new
multiplayer survival game that fans of
pokemon are sure to enjoy
let's check it out
[Music]
can't wait to check that one out
well it looks like we're at the end of
the show it's been an honor doug
check the back of your script i think we
missed something okay
do you also have one more thing written
in blood is that normal yes i do and no
this is not normal
i'm gonna go sharpen my silver sword
so
now that really is the end of our show
but remember to try out all the demos on
our future game show steam page and head
on over to gamesradar.com for more
follow-up coverage on all of the games
that you've seen today
i'd like to say a big thank you to
everyone involved in this year's future
games show powered by mana and of course
you guys watching at home i'm doug
cockle and i'm denise gough and this has
been future game show june 2022.
it's lights out and away we go
all analysis conclude that you have most
likely survived
[Applause]
[Music]
mana is the gaming rewards debit card
that puts the power back in the hands of
players so with every quest you complete
and every purchase you make you're
earning for the rewards you actually
want
we make it easy for you to set up and
start just sync your favorite games to
your mana account and start earning real
life rewards the next time you play
so why pay any other way
pay with mana pay with power
mana
game the system
[Music]
welcome back to gamespot's coverage of
summer game fest 2022. we just got
done watching future game show i'm kurt
devina your host joined with
davonte chisholm
hey everyone have you ever
you stole it from me
have you ever just wanted to take your
shoes off in front of strangers
let me know in the chat dip your toes in
a puddle of coffee
ah for those of you who have no idea
what we're talking about um devante's
favorite person in the world doug
uh
voiced actor in witcher 3
i have to be really honest with you
folks watching right now
that show exhausted me
like
we saw a lot of games yeah i really
really pride future game show for just
like one after the other slamming and
stuff i've never seen before yep
but
however
i also i had this whole thing
you know just because you're talking a
lot
doesn't mean you're saying that much
and i feel like we saw a lot
um
and it was really you know
just because you have a lot to show
doesn't mean yeah um
every single one of them is going to be
being or not that they need to be i'm
really glad that those showcases have a
place yeah to show these things off
because there were new things i learned
about yeah and there's always something
for someone out there no matter what
they are so but i by the time it was
over i was like i forgot i have a list i
have an ongoing list of every single
game we saw and then during the reel
then i was like
oh my god there was like this game day
show that was today they showed that
like the beginning of the showcase but
please talk to me about uh your favorite
voice actor and how uh he wants nothing
more to take your shoes off no and show
them to strangers that's something that
this is there is content so if if you
weren't here before uh this showcase
began i kind of expressed
the fact that the voice actors for
jennifer and girl from uh the witcher 3
wild hunt were going to be hosting this
and maybe we would get a sprinkle of
something oh we got a sprinkle or
something we did not get a sprinkle of
hey we're a part of witcher 4 or which
or whatever it's called
but there were a lot of witcher
references and a lot of jokes that just
kind of ran its course throughout the
show but
hey
sure
i'm i'm still a witcher fan you know
yeah you walk away from me like i'm done
it's not going to burn my jersey i'm
throwing out my jersey after that
i love it i love that they did it i love
that i'm walking away with one of my
favorite possibly top three favorite
moments of of this festival so far yeah
one of them is definitely the rock
yeah for sure listen is in his iron
palace for sure stay focused drink drink
this energy drink play games black adam
fortnite black adams drink this and now
um
girl
have you ever just wanted to take your
shoes off
show somebody your feet
jump in a puddle
if you just wanted to take your pants
off and which was a lead-in to airport
sim
which also felt a little
like i i guess out of place but at the
same time it's like you know people take
their shoes off at the airport or
airplane
don't do that yeah i mean i could see i
mean maybe girl would be like you ever
take your shoes off
this is in a bathtub i mean if geralt
shows how to take your boots off you
know
let's talk about games let's talk about
here we saw a lot of games uh so many to
too many of the lists but i will go
let's go over some themes
one yeah because there was a there was a
decent amount of them one major theme
that i think just goes beyond just what
we saw a future game show but a thing
that has been popping up over the past
few days is
cards
cards there's a lot of cards and games
these days yeah like before we really
before this was happening we were having
some exclusive looks at some games we're
playing one of them being midnight sons
xcom inspired style marvel game got
cards in it card based system that's
fine yeah that's cool we had inscription
that's a card game we got card
shark card shark that came out from
devolver this week
card game
a lot of cards at this point uh let's go
we got nightingale that's a survival
crafting uh
open shared world
kind of game
cool vibe cool kind of steampunk
gaslight vibe kind of giving me fallout
76 things another game that uses cards
nightingale uses cards
it's it's really pop i don't really get
why
it comes with become so popular um
but hey listen you know if it's
if cards need their little time in in
the spotlight and then we move into a
different type of like combat system or
decision making system sure
there's on dice
there is uh what was the um
that uh the game you're kind of excited
for music oh uh it was called power
chord it was they they led into it
saying like rogue like like kind of
music rhythm game or something and then
i was i was just like ooh perked up
leaned forward and then like card based
combat i was like oh man i thought it
was
a little something else
so that was a big theme was cards
uh there's one more there's one
announcement i want to talk about real
quick before we get into some of the
other ones because this is very specific
to me okay so out of nowhere
something this was a genuine surprise
deadly premonition to a blessing
disguise was announced during the future
game show
uh pc port available now on steam while
that was happening i had someone
messaging me be like your favorite game
just got put on steam i was like what
are you talking about what's my favorite
game what's my favorite game so many
announcements popping up on the screen
there's too much there's cards there's
roguelikes there's cards i don't know
what you're talking about and then all
of a sudden deadly permission two pops
up
uh
five out of ten
gamespot.com
reviewed by curtin davina
i'm a big fan of deadly permission one i
would say it's like one of my favorite
games of all time yeah uh deadly
permission two
it's got its problems but it's also got
i think it has plenty of reasons for
fans to play it but one thing with that
game is that frame rate the moment you
walk out into the open world
falls off a cliff it's got to be like 10
frames per second or less it's all over
the place so uh something else so but
like it's on pc right now yep
i have to i have to know yeah and the
good thing about it being on pc is that
even if it isn't great frame rate right
now
well that's the thing the first one came
to pc and it was an utter disaster oh
really barely the first one came to pc
and it was like not like the moment you
get into the open world
your car is like flying in the air
because the the physics is attached to
the frame rain you have no idea what's
happening yeah am i gonna buy deadly
permission too five out of ten game by
curtain devina yeshua on steam yeah yes
i'm going to you have cause i need to
know legally obligated you need to buy
it but that was a sincere surprise i
mean like uh
anything related to deadly permission is
always a surprise to me i can't help it
even if i didn't like it they dropped
three
would you would you want a three
that's a no but you play it
you you'd want to see what it happened
uh recently
uh
sweerie the the kind of director writer
of double premises
and his team put out the good life
this year i think it was last year
last year the good life was like and
that to me is a true spiritual successor
to deadly premonition it's a small town
kind of vibe
uh
there's there's there's a murder mystery
element all the things are there but
it's also very wholesome it's also very
quirky that to me was a better spiritual
successor but that's besides the point
that's we're not talking about future
game show for those of you just tuning
in we are here to do a post show on the
future game show which just showed a lot
and we talked about cards
your favorite my favorite we saw some
horror games when it comes to more
horror games your favorite we saw yeah
we even saw some vr ones my absolute
favorite that's the best immersion name
of the game
what's not literally the name of the
game but you know that's what you really
want when you're playing a horror game
immersion how do you feel like you know
coming off like we've seen so much
and future game shows definitely not
pulling anything back in terms of uh
being
i want to say saturated comes off word
but just like there's a lot there yeah
how you feeling
like i don't
i don't want to sound negative about it
but like i got to be like truthful with
it you know there was
i felt like that you know how ironic it
is that it's called future game show and
yet everything we saw in that felt like
games of the past or games that are
already available you know we have
pokemon but it's pokemon with guns we
have rocket league but it's rock it's
golf you know we have um
roguelikes yeah bloodborne roguelikes
yup exactly all of the games that kind
of look like
you know salt and sacrifice and and
pikmin and you know and i get it a lot
of the teams that are making these games
are very small teams maybe some of them
even one person
um
but yeah it just looked like a lot of
the games would pop up and immediately
we would go oh it's this yeah i you
bring up a good point like it's one of
like we like we basically had something
for everyone in there but whether or not
that's a good thing i don't know
i wouldn't say it was necessarily a safe
show by any means
like because we did see each i would say
we saw stuff like we saw like things i
have not heard of but you are right we
had like that boomer shooter escape you
know like there's that you know we were
talking about this during the before the
previews like during the show where it's
like doom 2016 came out and now we're
like seeing all these developers just
like catching up with that and like
putting out their own version of it yep
uh rhythm shooters
our genre that's like
kicking out of the gate we got another
one resource resource management is also
another
one like those never really went
anywhere but it seems like a lot of
games are popping up
where you're managing resources crafting
and you know having your your space base
building and all of that stuff and
nightingale is one of the things
on that kind of on that topic we have a
we do have an interview between lucy
james our very own lucy james uh and i
think uh i don't want to get it wrong
but aaron flynn
um who's the gp
for nightingale uh we have an interview
an exclusive interview on gamespot
youtube.com forward slash gamespot check
it out if you're interested but nine
gale was a game that's like it's it's it
has it's hitting those marks so a shared
world
survival yep crafting a game but
something that i thought was kind of
cool about and it's also a steampunk
thing it's just like we have these very
specific genres these very specific
vibes they just kind of seem to like
some weird creatures in there too
but while i was watching it i couldn't
help but be like this kind of looks like
in a good way in a good way by the way
fallout 76 yeah which i never played so
i can i could just go and we're going to
detail and just
have no
comparisons to make and yeah feel good
about myself but it's like we had games
like valheim that
blew up yeah last year like v rising yes
um
yes on the come up too that's rising yes
something something everything's rising
so but i do agree with you it's like we
everything we saw
not everything that's not everything
yeah but you know like i agree that like
we saw a lot of new things
but maybe not necessarily
uh things that were distinct or
distinctly original
it's all like you brought a good thing
like
tiny ken
the pikmin kind of thing like i think
that game has a really like has its own
identity that's for sure we saw a lot of
games that like were very much like oh
this is of this thing this is inspired
by this specific thing but still it's
like it's got its thing going on i think
tunican looks a little interesting as a
big old
pikmin fan yeah
where are you at where's all the
nintendo games so that's for another
time
um
and then i
but you know i was looking at what was i
just about to mention
ludo is that that's another thing too
like we talked about doing dune 2016 all
these games kind of catch up
breath of the wild comes out 2017. now
five years later we saw these games
catching up coming up with these wild
likes i don't know what the hell you
want to call those ones wildlife
breath likes breath likes breathe
breathe breathers um
and pt comes out what 2014.
and now it's like that pt train of like
these these these full like taking that
and trying to like create a full fledge
which is hilarious to me because like
you know you say come out but it didn't
even it didn't even so for it to get
close even off of just a demo is just
like man
what an influential
little slice though imagine if that game
actually happened
but ludo is a game that we saw very
early in the showcase
uh that was like very clearly
leaning into
you know picking up what pt threw up in
the air now everybody's trying to grab
it we had visage that's another horror
game you love horror yeah i can't wait
to play luna yeah
it seems great
but not to switch gears off horror
because i know we want to talk about how
much you love we want to talk about that
forever um but we saw american arcadia
again again
which is interesting that it's popping
up everywhere like you mentioned that
the um raw fury must be very confident
in this game to have it all over every
showcase yeah and i feel like
yeah we saw a summer game fest
uh we saw it during was it tribal we
started doing try background i guess
there's like little there's other ones
in the middle that we haven't seen it
out like wholesome i guess this wouldn't
be a wholesome game you're trying to
escape the city or something like that
yeah so
but we've seen it a decent amount of
times and it it kind of makes me wonder
if we're gonna see it tomorrow
like is this the end of american arcadia
at least i mean we're talking about it
yeah i've had just like just for like
for uh summer games fest or
is it gonna pop up maybe not at xbox but
uh pc
maybe or something like that let's just
assume we're gonna put bets on it okay
we got like every time we see it we see
a little more about it which i think is
kind of interesting it's like we're like
we're not seeing entirely the same
trailer over and over and over again
we're getting like you know little new
snippets of it which shows which tells
me that like raw fury must really like
really think this game must be
interesting it must be cool i think it
looks interesting i think it looks cool
this first person uh between you know
escape
yeah being the person who like helps
this other than goes this 2d thing but
um
yeah you're right but i mean look i
think the feature game show is fantastic
at what they do
just want to sometimes i just i watch
and i'm like
don't you just want to take your shoes
off
i don't know why i didn't see it going
that way
[Laughter]
um
but yeah any clothes this is the
closeout for the day folks davonte how
do you feel do you feel you know
you're looking forward what are you
looking forward to
i guess you know at this point
just gotta look forward to xbox like
that's that's at the top of everyone's
minds right now i know everybody's
thinking about it with uh with with
these with today's showcases kind of
winding down and stuff it's like
big one right around the corner yeah
yeah yeah tomorrow which reminds me if
you folks are watching tuning in right
now or i've been watching all day first
off thank you for joining us thank you
for being you know doing a game spot
hanging out with me curtain davina
hanging out devonte just breathtaking
who is they are they are um
uh but hey uh thanks for being here
we're gonna wrap up the day but just
want to remind you folks who have tons
of exclusive content on our website
gamespot.com as well as our youtube
channel youtube.com forward slash
gamespot today before uh right after
wholesome games we got a look at uh some
hands-on impressions of street fighter
six we looked at midnight's suns we also
looked at lego brawl and then of course
uh nightingale which we saw today during
the future game show we do have an
exclusive interview over there for you
to go check out if you would like that
said we'll be back tomorrow so please
come back hang out with us we got xbox
90 minutes of xox bethesda showcase
and then right after that we got the pc
game show so we got a lot we got a lot
clear your calendars clear your
schedules drink some water drink some
water
be cool be well thank you so much curtin
divina devonte chisholm
till next time folks see you tomorrow
[Music]
you